I'm Jennifer Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies.
我是珍妮弗·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。
Hello Angela. Hi there. Hi everyone. Helloates. Hello, Angela. Hi there. Hi, everyone. Hello, hello. Is everybody ready for a garden party? Well, I am wearing my Connecticut casual outfit, so. Good.
你好，安吉拉。嗨。大家好。各位好。嗨，安吉拉。嗨。大家好。嗨，嗨。大家准备好参加花园派对了吗？嗯，我穿着我的康涅狄格休闲装，所以。很好。
Good. This is season eight, episode four, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Dave Rogers. Here is your summary. Andy throws a dignified garden party at Shrute Farms under the guise of impressing Robert California, but it soon becomes clear that he is really trying to impress his parents who clearly favor his younger brother Walter Jr. Meanwhile, Pam and Angela discover they have chosen the same name for their unborn sons, and Jim plays a very elaborate prank on Dwight. Very elaborate. We'll get into
很好。这是第八季第四集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯导演。这是剧情梗概：安迪在施鲁特农场举办了一场高雅的花园派对，借口是给罗伯特·加利福尼亚留下深刻印象，但很快人们就发现，他真正想讨好的是他的父母，而他的父母显然更偏爱他的弟弟小沃尔特。与此同时，帕姆和安吉拉发现她们为尚未出生的儿子选择了同一个名字，吉姆对德怀特开了一个非常精心策划的玩笑。非常精心策划。我们这就来聊聊
it, but I was like, seriously, Jim? I have so many things to say about it, and so much male to read. I was going to say, I hope there was a fan male flurry. There certainly was. Well, listen to kick things off for this episode. We have an interview with the one, the only Walter Jr. Josh Groban. What a wonderful person. We had the best time talking to him. We can't wait for you to hear this interview. I was on a high all day after we had our interview. Smiling all day. Now listen, Josh Grobin, Grammy-nominated singer-songwriter. In 2003, he won two Billboard Music Awards for classical crossover artist of the year and classical crossover album of the year for Closer. His first four solo albums all went multi-platinum, and in 2007 he was the number one best-selling artist in the United States.
这个，不过我当时想，说真的，吉姆？我有太多话想说，还有好多邮件要读。我本来想说，我希望有一阵粉丝邮件狂潮。确实有。好了，听着，为这一集拉开序幕的是我们对唯一的小沃尔特·杰哥——乔什·格罗班的采访。多好的人啊。和他聊天我们度过了最美好的时光。我们等不及让你听到这个采访了。我们在采访结束后整整一天都处于亢奋状态。一整天都在微笑。现在听着，乔什·格罗班，获得格莱美提名的歌手兼词曲作家。2003年，他凭专辑《Closer》赢得了两项公告牌音乐奖：年度古典跨界艺人和年度古典跨界专辑。他的前四张个人专辑全部达到多白金销量，2007年他是美国销量第一的畅销艺人。
And as of 2022, he has sold over 25 million records worldwide. Wow. I mean, seriously. In 2007, he starred in Natasha Pierre and the great Commit of 1812 on Broadway. He was nominated for a Tony award for Best Actor in a leading role in a musical, and he is now currently starring in Sweeney Todd on Broadway. It has been nominated for eight Tony Awards, including Best Actor in a musical for Josh Groben. It is running right now through January 2024. I'm going to get to see this in just a few weeks. I cannot wait. I know. I wish I was with you. I'm so bombed. You're gonna have to tell us all about it.
截至2022年，他的唱片全球销量已超过2500万张。哇。我是说，真的。2007年，他在百老汇主演了《娜塔莎、皮埃尔与1812年大彗星》。他获得过托尼奖音乐剧最佳男主角提名，目前他正在百老汇主演《理发师陶德》。该剧获得了包括乔什·格罗班音乐剧最佳男主角在内的八项托尼奖提名。演出将一直持续到2024年1月。我再过几周就要去看这个剧了。我等不及了。我知道。我真希望我和你一起去。我太失望了。你得把一切都告诉我们。
I absolutely will. Well, I guess without further ado, here's our interview with Josh Groban. Oh my gosh, Josh! Hello! Josh, this is so exciting. Angela and Jenna, I'm so excited to be with you. It's been a really long time since I've seen either of you. Angela and I did a kind of a web thing, a really fun comedy thing, a web series, not too long after we filmed our episode, but it's been a really, really long time.
我一定会的。好吧，话不多说，这就是我们对乔什·格罗班的采访。哦天哪，乔什！你好！乔什，太令人兴奋了。安吉拉和珍妮，我很高兴能和你们在一起。我见你们俩已经是很久以前的事了。我和安吉拉在拍完我们那一集后不久，做过一个网页节目，一个非常有趣的喜剧节目，一个网络系列剧，但那已经是好久好久以前的事了。
And Jenna, thank you so much for reaching out and for asking me to be part of this. Yes, I slid into your DMs on Instagram. You did. And I was so happy you got back to me. And I mean, I blew up Angela's phone. I was like, hey, roll back. She did.
珍妮，非常感谢你联系我并邀请我参与其中。是的，我在Instagram上私信了你（滑入你的私信）。你确实这么做了。我很高兴你回复了我。而且我的意思是，我把安吉拉的手机轰炸了。我说，嘿，有回复了。她确实这么做了。
She said, yes, he said, yes. I saw it. So thrilled. And that was very similar to how I wound up being on the office. In general, it was a DM slide. Okay, we wanted to ask you about this. You have to share with everyone. We always ask everyone, how did you get your part on the office? So you have to tell the story. Well, I mean, I can imagine that I was very similar to many people who were asked to be on the show, and that we were all just enormous fans of the show. And so to get a request to say, hey, this might be a fun thing for you to do,
她说，是的，他说，是的。我看到了。非常兴奋。这和我最终出演《办公室》的方式非常相似。总的来说，就是私信联系。好吧，我们想问你这个。你必须和大家分享。我们总是问每个人，你是怎么得到《办公室》的角色？所以你得讲讲这个故事。好吧，我想我和许多被邀请参演该剧的人非常相似，那就是我们都是该剧的超级粉丝。所以当收到邀请说，嘿，这可能是对你来说很有趣的一件事情，
was just like finding the golden ticket. It was an amazing thing. So Mindy Caling did the DM slide on the old Twitter. Remember Twitter? Yep. Oh, yeah. Those were the days. And so Mindy sent me a message saying,
就像找到了金券一样。这是一件了不起的事。所以明迪·卡灵在老推特上发了私信。还记得推特吗？是的。哦，是的。那可真是些好日子。所以明迪给我发了一条消息说，
hey, we're writing an episode. And we think there might be a role saying, hey, we're writing an episode and we think there might be a role that would be really fun for you. Are you in the LA area during this date? And I was on tour at that time. I was actually doing a really, really big tour at that time. And so I really didn't think when she mentioned it that I would have any time at all and it was going to absolutely crush my soul to not be able to do it.
嘿，我们正在写一集剧本。我们觉得可能有一个角色，嘿，我们正在写一集剧本，我们觉得可能有一个非常适合你的角色。这段时间你在洛杉矶地区吗？我当时正在巡演。事实上，我当时正在进行一次非常非常大型的巡演。所以我当时真的没想到她提到这事时我会有一点空闲时间，如果不能参加，我的心一定会碎的。
But it landed right when I was playing L.A. And so during my time off between shows, I was able to take a little road trip up to Shrewd Farms. And it was the best recharge I could have possibly imagined. It was so fun. I mean, I talk about it even to this day. It was really one of my most favorite days that I've ever had in the business or out of the business.
但它恰好落在我去洛杉矶演出的时候。所以在演出之间的休息时间，我得以去施鲁特农场进行了一次短途旅行。这是我能想象到的最好的充电方式。太有趣了。我是说，直到今天我还在谈论它。这真的是我在业内或业外度过的最喜欢的日子之一。
It was just the best. Oh my gosh, so what made it so fun? What'd you love about it? Well, I mean, having done now some TV since then, I can tell you that shooting at a lovely outdoor estate is a delight. To not be at a sound stage, to not have to spend 15 hours in a little box of a room where you're not seeing daylight and to be able to shoot a on a beautiful setting. But then also, again, as a fan of the show, to sometimes when you make a guest appearance on a show,
简直是棒极了。哦天哪，是什么让它这么有趣的？你喜欢它什么？好吧，既然我现在已经拍了一些电视剧，我可以告诉你，在一个可爱的户外庄园拍摄是一种享受。不用待在摄影棚里，不用在一个像小盒子一样的房间里度过15个小时看不到天日，而且能够在美丽的布景中拍摄。但同时，作为一个剧迷，有时当你客串一个节目时，
you're doing it with one person or two people from the show and you're part of like a little arc that doesn't involve other people in the cast. And so to be part of a everybody together doing a party scene meant that as a fanboy of the show, I got to sit and just be around the entire cast for the entirety of the day.
你只是和剧中的一个人或两个人一起拍，你是那种不涉及剧组其他人的小支线的一部分。所以能成为所有人一起聚会场景的一部分意味着，作为该剧的粉丝男孩，我得以坐下来，整整一天都和整个剧组待在一起。
And so it was just, I felt like I'd kind of like won an auction or something that like come hang it's root farms with the cast of the office. It was the best. And of course, because you're sitting around a lot during shooting of something, there's just a lot of time to just get to know everybody and get to know the writers and the wonderful crew
所以这让我感觉自己好像赢得了什么拍卖一样，可以和《办公室》的剧组一起在施鲁特农场闲逛。太棒了。当然，因为在拍摄某场戏时大家坐着等的时间很多，所以有很多时间去了解每个人，去了解编剧和优秀的剧组人员，
and just chat with everybody. And it was just such a dream. I loved location episodes just for that reason too. There was a lot of hanging out. I have a picture of us just all casually on the porch at Shrute Farms. And we're just chatting and we were also charmed by you, Josh. We were so excited. And I know I was trying to play it cool. I'm sure Jenna too, because we're two of the biggest dorks ever. But you are instantly, you are instantly Andy's brother. It was crazy. It was so perfect.
只是和每个人聊天。这简直就像一个梦想。我喜欢外景剧集也正是因为这个原因。有很多闲逛的时间。我有一张照片，是我们大家都很随性地坐在施鲁特农场的门廊上。我们只是在聊天，而且我们都被你迷住了，乔什。我们太兴奋了。我知道我当时在装酷。我敢肯定珍妮也是，因为我们是两个史上最大的书呆子。但你立刻，你立刻就是安迪的弟弟。太疯狂了。太完美了。
I loved that they wrote, you know, sometimes I play like myself. Yeah, like Parks and Rec, you played yourself. Like it parks and Rec, I played myself and Glee, I played myself. I'm just one of those people, like because my music side is like so serious, like whenever somebody wants me to play a bizarre version of me, it just like lets me kind of let that other side play around a little bit. And so I say yes to playing myself weirdly sometimes. This was an opportunity like this was really, really fun to play Andy's brother. And when Mindy and BJ kind of laid out for me, you know, what the story is, the jealousy, the sibling rivalry and the jealousy and why, you know, what the story is, the jealousy, the sibling rivalry,
我喜欢他们写的那样，你知道，有时候我扮演的是我自己。是的，就像在《公园与游憩》里，你扮演的是你自己。就像在《公园与游憩》里，我扮演我自己，在《欢乐合唱团》里，我扮演我自己。我就是那种人，因为我的音乐形象太严肃了，每当有人想让我扮演一个离奇版本的自己时，它就让我那种另一面的天性稍微玩一玩。所以我有时会奇怪地答应扮演我自己。这是一个机会，扮演安迪的弟弟真的非常非常有趣。当明迪和BJ向我勾勒出故事时，你知道，故事是关于什么的，嫉妒，手足之间的竞争和嫉妒，以及为什么，你知道，故事是关于什么的，嫉妒，手足之间的竞争，
and the jealousy, and why, you know, I got to be Walter Jr., and they passed over, you know, Ed. Yeah, the name is it. Yeah, exactly. It just every bit of it was so funny to me. My brother and I have the same birthday four years apart. So we had our own little sibling, we've never had any rivalry, but he's now my best friend and he's the best. But when you have to share a birthday, there's that weird sibling tension when it's like four and eight. Yeah, how do you do that party for both a four year old and an eight year old? Yeah. We discovered very early on that all, you know, because parties are organized by the parents at that age.
还有嫉妒，以及为什么，你知道，我成了小沃尔特，而他们忽略了，你知道，埃德。对，名字就是这样。对，完全是这样。这其中的每一小部分都让我觉得太好笑了。我和我哥哥是同一天生日，相差四岁。所以我们有我们自己的小手足，我们从没有任何竞争，但他现在是我最好的朋友，他是最棒的。但是当你不得不共同过生日时，当一个四岁一个八岁时，就会有一种奇怪的手足紧张感。对，你怎么能为四岁和八岁的小孩办一个派对呢？对。我们很早就发现，所有的，你知道的，因为那个年龄的派对是由父母组织的，
The kids, we're not in charge of presence, that we're just kids. So we realized very early on that the parents, if they knew that it was also big brother, Josh's birthday, they would bring a little extra present, you know, we got to bring a nice present, that's also. So we had, we figured out early on that same birthday meant double the presents. And so, uh, so we mean, we had a little deal. We had a little work. You made it work. Yes, we made it work. Yeah. One of the things I loved
孩子们，我们不负责礼物，我们只是小孩子。所以我们很早就意识到，如果父母知道这也是大哥哥乔什的生日，他们会带一个小小的额外礼物，你知道，我们得带一份不错的礼物，这也是。所以我们，我们很早就发现，同一个生日意味着双倍的礼物。所以，呃，所以我们，意思是，我们有了一个小小的交易。我们有了一个小小的协议。你让它成功了。是的，我们让它成功了。是的。我喜欢的一件事是
in rewatching this episode was that Andy's brother seems like he genuinely just loves Andy. He's his bro-nard and he was so excited to meet Tuna. Yes, exactly. He clearly looks up to his brother and I thought that was really nice. Whatever Andy's feeling, I didn't feel like his brother was trying to stir the pot. Totally. I think that a lot of it is, you know, is within Andy. There's a lot of, there's a lot of stuff that Andy's kind of like, you know, needs therapy about, but it's, it's,
在重温这一集时，我发现安迪的弟弟似乎真的只是爱安迪。他是他的兄弟，而且他非常高兴能见到金枪鱼（Tuna）。对，完全是这样。他显然很崇拜他的哥哥，我觉得这真的很棒。不管安迪有什么感觉，我不觉得他弟弟是在挑起事端。完全同意。我认为很大一部分是，你知道的，是安迪自身的问。安迪有很多，有很多事情，你知道，需要去看心理医生，但这，
and that's that can happen. Maybe at some point, there was a little bit of that rub, but I think that now it's like everybody's grown up, and I think that truly, I felt one of the things I loved about Walter Jr. is that he's like this super talented golden retriever that just doesn't know. He's like, oh, yeah, sure, I'll go fetch that acoustic guitar and sing this beautiful and jealous song for all of you. And Andy, it's just eating him up inside. And I think that that kind of lack of awareness
而且那是有可能的。也许在某个时候，有过一点摩擦，但我认为现在就像大家都长大了，而且我认为真的，我喜欢小沃尔特的一点是，他就像一只超级有才华的金毛寻回犬，只是自己不知道。他就像，哦，是的，当然，我去把那把木吉他拿来，为你们所有人唱这首美丽而嫉妒的歌。而安迪，这在内心折磨着他。我认为这种缺乏意识
was one of the things that really made that dynamic really adorable and really fun. And, you know, I think the parents knew better a little bit, but I don't think Walter Jr. knew better. I think Walter Jr. is just, you know, living his dream. And it's like, there's always those people out there that just have that little extra serotonin that you're just like, how, that must be nice.
正是让那种动态变得非常可爱和有趣的因素之一。而且，你知道，我认为父母心里多少有点数，但我认为小沃尔特并不知道。我认为小沃尔特只是，你知道，在过着他的梦想生活。而且就像，总会有那些人，他们身上有多那么一点血清素，你会想，怎么会这样，那一定很美好。
How do you, how do you, God, if I could live in that brain for just one day, that would be really, really fun. And I think that Walter Jr. is one of those people where he keeps falling up. And Andy's just had to be kind of next to that at all times. And a side note to that, which is really funny because now I'm doing Sweeney Todd, is that one of my other very favorite episodes of the office is the Sweeney Todd episode. And it's one that we all kind of quote and love very much backstage at our Sweeney Todd,
你怎么能，你怎么能，天哪，如果我能在那个大脑里生活哪怕一天，那也会真的非常非常有趣。而且我认为小沃尔特就是那种总能因祸得福的人。而安迪不得不时刻陪伴在那种人身边。顺便提一下，这真的很有趣，因为现在我正在演《理发师陶德》，《办公室》里另一个我最喜欢的剧集是《理发师陶德》那一集。那是我们在后台经常引用并且非常喜欢的一集，在我们《理发师陶德》的后台，
is that of course Andy, you know, is in Sweeney Todd and is Antony in Sweeney Todd. And now you're in Sweeney Todd, but you're the lead. And you're on Broadway. Yes, so you have bested him again. I have bested him yet again. And that is the universe being so weird and so wonderful. And so yes, yeah, it's great.
那就是安迪，你知道的，在《理发师陶德》里，并且是《理发师陶德》里的安东尼。而现在你在《理发师陶德》里，但你是主角。而且你在百老汇。是的，所以你再次胜过他了。我又一次胜过他了。这就是命运如此奇妙又如此美好。所以，是的，这太棒了。
But I'm hoping at some point, Ed and I can really kind of sit down and have a proper talk and hug it out. That would be awesome. When you were on set, Josh, did you ever break in a scene? Oh, yeah, all the time. Oh, yeah, absolutely. I guess one of my questions for you, because I was only, I did two episodes and spent a day doing each episode,
但我希望在某个时候，埃德和我真的能坐下来好好谈谈，来个大大的拥抱。那太棒了。乔什，当你在片场时，你有没有在拍戏时笑场过？哦，是的，经常。哦，是的，绝对有。我想我问你的问题之一是，因为我只拍了两集，每集花了一天时间，
but I kind of wanted to ask you guys as well. You know, was there always room for improv on your days? Because the scripts were brilliant. Each one, every time I read it, it was so conversational and it felt so natural. And there were oftentimes things that were written that if I hadn't known, it was written. I would think, oh, that must have been an improvised line.
但我也想问问你们。你知道，在你们的日子里，总有即兴发挥的空间吗？因为剧本太精彩了。每一个，每次我读它，它都那么具有对话感，感觉那么自然。而且很多时候写出来的东西，如果我事先不知道那是写好的，我可能会想，哦，那一定是一句即兴台词。
And that's just how wonderful it was. But there was such wonderful improv happening at Shrute Farms. Everybody was just kind of pitching things and even off camera. Just so everybody's just so funny. K-flinery was always finding new ways to like get me, you know? And with like the idea of like pulling my vocal cords out
这就是它的美妙之处。但在施鲁特农场发生了很多美妙的即兴发挥。每个人都在提出各种想法，甚至在镜头外也是如此。只是每个人都太有趣了。凯·弗莱纳瑞总是能找到新方法来整我，你知道吗？比如想把我的声带从
of my throat, you know that kind of thing. And so yeah, I mean, was that always encouraged or was that something that kind of developed over time or was that just the writing made that something that kind of developed over time or Or was that just the writing made it seem that way at all times? It was sort of all of those things. I mean it did always start with an amazing script But it was always a living breathing thing so the writers of that episode and the producers would come down and They were always pitching alternate lines pitching
喉咙里扯出来，你知道那种事情。所以，是的，我是说，这总是受到鼓励的，还是随着时间推移发展出来的一种东西，或者仅仅是剧本让它看起来一直都是那样的？这可以说是所有这些因素的结合。我是说，它确实总是从一个惊艳的剧本开始。但它一直是一个有生命的、呼吸着的东西，所以那一集的编剧和制片人会下来，他们总是在提出备选台词，提出
Yeah, and they would throw them out to the actors or the actors might have an idea They were always pitching alternate lines. Pitching. Yeah. And they would throw them out to the actors, or the actors might have an idea in the moment. And it was always allowed. Yeah. You know, as long as we had gotten it in a scripted way, at least once, then we could play around. Right.
是的，他们会把台词抛给演员，或者演员当时可能会有想法。而且这总是被允许的。是的。你知道，只要我们至少按剧本演过一次，我们就可以自由发挥了。对。
That's really cool. And also just being kind of like an outsider in the group, I had not done a lot of acting at that time, and I had certainly not done a lot of comedy acting at that time. And so to be around so many very funny, very talented people, we got to like share stories about like our different worlds. Like so what's touring like, you know,
这真的很酷。而且作为一个圈外人，我当时没有演过很多戏，我当然也没有演过很多喜剧。所以能和这么多非常有趣、非常有才华的人在一起，我们得以分享关于我们不同世界的故事。比如巡演是什么样的，你知道吗，
and so you know, it actually kind of turned into like a real garden party, but like we just, you know, just getting yogurt from craft. And you know, it was was just really, really fun. Really cool. It was a hot day though, remember that? It was so hot that day. I found an email that Jen and I traded back and forth
所以你知道，它实际上有点像变成了一个真正的花园派对，只是我们，你知道，从剧组零食区拿酸奶。你知道，这真的，真的很酷。不过那天很热，还记得吗？那天太热了。我找到了一封我和珍妮来回发邮件的邮件，
about how hot it was and how that they had these huge tubes of air. And we were all fighting about where you could sit. So the tube of air would hit you. And they turned them on whenever we took a break in scenes and everyone would like go around the tube, except in this email I said, unfortunately, Ellie was sitting basically right on top of the tube.
关于天气有多热，以及他们有那些巨大的风扇管道。我们都在争论你可以坐在哪里。这样风扇管道就会吹到你身上。每当我们在场景中休息时，他们就会打开风扇管道，每个人都会围着管道转，除了在这封邮件里我说，不幸的是，艾莉基本上就坐在管道正上方。
Like the tube kind of came right out to her chair. And she was freezing and the rest of us were like, pull the tube this way, we're running up. Apparently the tubes were a big deal during the shoot. Wow. And she was even pepier in those scenes. And that's the reason why. Oh my God, that's so funny, every gathering around the coolant tube.
就像管道直接通到她的椅子上一样。她冻得要命，而我们其余的人则在喊，把管道拉这边来，我们要烤化了。显然这些管道在拍摄期间是个大事件。哇。而且她在那些场景中更有活力了。这就是原因。哦天哪，太搞笑了，每个人都围着冷气管道。
Yeah, it was very, very hot. You said you hadn't done a lot of acting but you had just been in crazy stupid love with Steve Crouch. That's actually true. Which is crazy. Which was like one of my first things that I ever did. You know, outside of music and that was not a DM slide getting it. Steve Steve did not do it. It was proper. Did not slide into my DMs for that role. I still wish that was the story behind that though. Can we just say that that's what it was. I want to rewrite this. No, here's the thing.
是的，非常非常热。你说你没演过很多戏，但你刚刚和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起演了《疯狂愚蠢的爱》。这确实是真的。太疯狂了。那是我做过的第一批事情之一。你知道，在音乐之外，而且这不是通过私信拿到的角色。史蒂夫并没有这么做。这是正规的。没有为了那个角色给我的私信滑轨。不过我还是希望那是背后的故事。我们能就说那是怎么回事吗？我想重写这个。不，事情是这样的。
No, it was, that was such a fun shoot as well. It was again, just a couple days. We shot at the Glendale Galleria. And we shot all night at like an El Torrito. I know the Glendale Galleria. Yeah. Yeah, the Glendale Galleria. Every time I drive by it, getting onto the 101. I was like,
不，那是一次非常有趣的拍摄。同样只是几天。我们在格伦代尔广场（Glendale Galleria）拍摄。我们在一家埃尔托里托（El Torrito）餐厅通宵拍摄。我知道格伦代尔广场。是的。格伦代尔广场。每次我开车路过它，上101国道时。我都想，
yeah, that's, I had a lot of tortilla chips. Yeah. That's where I had my first on-screen kiss. But weren't you a theater major? I was a theater major, but I got plucked out of college when I got a recording contract. It was a weird fork in the road and one that has, you know, afforded me some extraordinary experiences like this one. But it was my first love was was doing theater. My first and my first love before that was doing comedy and doing improv. I was very lucky to do a lot of improv in high school and junior high school. It kind of like got me out of my shell when I was really, really shy and having a hard time making friends and my grades weren't great. I just was kind of trapped.
是的，那，我吃了很多玉米片。是的。那是我第一次在银幕上接吻的地方。但你不是戏剧专业出身吗？我是戏剧专业出身的，但当我获得唱片合约时，我被从大学里挖走了。这是一个奇怪的十字路口，它为我提供了一些非凡的体验，比如这次体验。但我的初恋是做戏剧。我的初恋，在此之前我的初恋是演喜剧和即兴表演。我很幸运在高中和初中时做了很多即兴表演。它让我走出了外壳，当我非常非常害羞，很难交到朋友，成绩也不太好时。我当时有点被困住了。
And joining the school improv troop and being able to be part of a youth second-city class when I was 11 and being part of the LA Connection Comedy Theatre in the Valley when I was 13 and 14. Those kinds of improv games were so good for that muscle and my brain that had not been activated at that point and was so great for me being social and being able to, because improv is all about kind of saying yes and really listening and being part of that and when you're closed off as a kid, those things
加入学校的即兴剧团，在我11岁时能够成为青少年第二城（Second City）班级的一员，在我13岁和14岁时成为山谷中洛杉矶连接喜剧剧院（LA Connection Comedy Theatre）的一员。那种即兴游戏对锻炼那个当时还没有被激活的肌肉和我的大脑非常有益，对我的社交能力和能够，因为即兴表演完全就是关于表示同意（Yes, and），真正倾听并参与其中，而当你作为一个小孩子时你是封闭的，那些事情
kind of get stunted and so it was finding the rhythm of comedy was something that really got me out of my shell long before finding the rhythm of music. And then that fork in the road happened. And it's been the most incredible journey of my life to be able to be a solo artist, to make music and sing for people. But every time I've had an opportunity to step back into the camaraderie of acting and comedy and theater, it's an absolute blast. You are speaking to my improv heart.
有点发育不良，所以找到喜剧的节奏是我真正让我走出外壳的因素，远在找到音乐的节奏之前。然后那个十字路口就出现了。能够成为一名独唱艺人，创作音乐并为人们歌唱，这是我一生中最不可思议的旅程。但每当我有机会重新回到表演、喜剧和戏剧的同事情谊中时，绝对是一场狂欢。你简直是在对我的即兴灵魂说话。
My improv heart is singing. I've moved around a lot as a kid. And one of the ways I would connect is through improv class or sketch comedy and just being an outsider, it was a way in. And I actually had my kids do an improv class. And it was so adorable. And at the the same time the very first minute I sat there on their performance night and they came out and they started doing these improv games that I had done. I started crying. My husband was like, I don't think you should be crying. But I was just like, I'm so moved that these same games are there and it's yes and in the moment and listening and trust.
我的即兴灵魂在歌唱。我小时候经常搬家。我建立联系的方式之一就是通过即兴表演课或素描喜剧，作为一个局外人，这是一个切入点。我实际上让我的孩子去上即兴表演课。太可爱了。与此同时，当我坐在他们的表演之夜的第一分钟，他们出来开始做这些我做过的即兴游戏时。我开始哭了。我丈夫说，我觉得你不应该哭。但我只是觉得，我太感动了，这些相同的游戏还在那里，而且就是顺着说下去并即时反应、倾听和信任。
And trust. There's so much trust involved in it. And the idea is nothing like it in the world. The idea of going out, not knowing what's going to happen. And trusting yourself and trusting the people that are around you. I just recently did four or five performances of this wonderful show that was on Broadway. It's not there anymore. It's called Free Style Love Supreme, which is kind of a music.
还有信任。其中涉及太多的信任。这种感觉世上无二。走出去，不知道会发生什么。信任自己，信任周围的人。我最近做了四五场这个精彩演出的表演，这个节目曾在百老汇上演。现在不在了。它叫《自由式最高法院》（Free Style Love Supreme），有点像音乐剧。
It was like a music improv show that Lin-Manuel Miranda and a number of other incredible freestyle rappers and musicians kind of put together. And it's comedy, it's rap, it's music, and they said, hey, will you come out and like sing and improvise love song every night? We'll interview an audience member, and then we'll come up with a song together. And every single time, you know, I asked Lin, like, do you have any advice for how to make the successful? And he said, yeah, the first thing is, take a half shot of whiskey. Second thing is, don't prepare anything.
它就像是一个音乐即兴表演秀，由林-曼努尔·米兰达和许多其他出色的自由式说唱歌手和音乐家共同打造。这是喜剧，是说唱，是音乐，他们说，嘿，你愿意出来每天晚上唱一首即兴情歌吗？我们会采访一位观众，然后我们一起想出一首歌。每一次，你知道的，我问林，比如，你对如何取得成功有什么建议吗？他说，是的，第一件事是，喝半小杯威士忌。第二件事是，什么都不要准备。
You're gonna be really tempted to write lines that you're gonna wanna, you know, shoehorn into the song because you think they're clever and whatever else. And he said, that part of your brain that has lines prepared is gonna be clashing with the part of your brain that's going to be receiving what the night is giving you and what the audience is giving you, and it's going to make you stumble. So go out there with a clear mind, open heart, and a lot of trust, and it'll come. And then like
你会非常想写一些你想要硬塞进歌里的台词，因为你觉得它们很聪明什么的。他说，你大脑中准备好台词的那部分会与你大脑中接受当晚发生的事情和观众给你的东西的那部分发生冲突，这会让你结结巴巴。所以带着清醒的头脑、敞开的心扉和高度的信任走出去，它就会自然流露。然后像
the first time I went out there, it was like gangbusters, it was great. Second, I'm thinking that was a fluke. And the second night, it was gangbusters. And that's just, and it just was that way every time you just trust that it's going to be there for you. And it's for kids, it's why I'm such a proponent of these kinds of experiences for young students, because those moments, those aha moments, those little light bulb flips change the course of a young person's life, even if they don't go into the arts and comedy and theater and music. In fact, many times they won't, but it will make them a far more well-rounded and confident doctor and lawyer, and the people that come up to me in jobs that are not considered creative that said that arts and comedy and improv and musical theater and all that stuff
我第一次走出去时，就像大获成功一样，太棒了。第二次，我以为那是侥幸。第二天晚上，它大获成功。就是这样，每次你只要相信它会为你而在。对于孩子们来说，这就是为什么我如此支持年轻学生有这种经历，因为那些时刻，那些“啊哈”时刻，那些小灯泡亮起的瞬间，改变了一个年轻人的生活轨迹，即使他们没有从事艺术、喜剧、戏剧和音乐。事实上，很多时候他们不会，但它会让他们成为一个更加全面、自信的医生和律师，那些从事不被认为具有创造力的工作的人来到我面前说，艺术、喜剧、即兴表演和音乐剧以及所有这些东西
changed the course of their life. It's incredible. Josh, I was trying not to fan-girl too hard at the beginning of this life, it's incredible. Josh, I was trying not to fan girl too hard at the beginning of this interview and now you have made it impossible. Yeah, forget it, forget it. Well, I am speechless. That was beautiful. I'm trying not to do the same thing.
改变了他们的人生轨迹。太不可思议了。乔什，我刚才在这次采访开始时尽量不在追星，现在你让我无法做到了。是的，算了吧，算了吧。好吧，我无言以对。太美妙了。我也在努力克制自己。
I will say there's also a really, I think. So I mentioned the LA Connection Comedy Theater, which is a wonderful place. I spent like a few months doing classes there and doing some stuff there. I was like 16, they were really cool to me and they really provided me with a wonderful opportunity there. I think there's a very odd mural of me
我要说的是，还有一个非常，我想。我刚才提到洛杉矶连接喜剧剧院，这是一个非常棒的地方。我在那里花了几个月的时间上课并做一些事情。我当时16岁，他们对我很好，并在那里为我提供了一个绝佳的机会。我想那里有一幅非常奇怪的壁画，
on the side of the building, like me and some other alumni that went there. I think Will Farrell is painted up there. I think Matthew Perry is painted up there. There's some discussion of whether it's me or Keanu Reeves painted up there. I think Matthew Perry is painted up there. There's some discussion of whether it's me or Keanu Reeves painted up there, but I don't think Keanu Reeves went to the Ellen's Comedy Theater.
在建筑物的侧面，画着我和其他一些去过那里的校友。我想威尔·法瑞尔被画在上面了。我想马修·佩里被画在上面了。关于上面画的是我还是基努·里维斯，还有一些争论。我想马修·佩里被画在上面了。关于上面画的是我还是基努·里维斯，还有一些争论，但我认为基努·里维斯没有去过爱伦喜剧剧院。
So. I think this is a mom detective moment, Jenna. I think we need to drive over there. We will check this out for you. I believe it's on Ventura Boulevard. And it's like directly across from like one of those Halloween, you know, costume and story and stories, you know, somebody sent it to me on Twitter. And then I was,
所以。我觉得这是一个妈妈侦探时刻，珍妮。我觉得我们需要开车过去看看。我们会为你查证这个。我相信它在文图拉大道（Ventura Boulevard）上。它正对着其中一家万圣节，你知道的，服装店，你知道的，有人在推特上发给我。然后我，
I was looking for a costume last minute, last Halloween. And I was like, Oh, yeah. Oh, my girlfriend just sent me this picture. Your listeners can't look at it. But this is the wall. Yeah. Yeah. If you send that to us, we'll put it on the office lady's pod Instagram. Yes, that's you. That is you. But it could be Keanu as well. But it could be Keanu. It could be Keanu.
万圣节前夕我在找一套最后一分钟的服装。然后我想，哦，对了。我女朋友刚给我发了这张照片。你们的听众看不到它。但这就是那堵墙。是的。如果你把那个发给我们，我们会把它发到《办公室辣妈》播客的Instagram上。是的，那是你。那就是你。但它也可以是基努。但它也可以是基努。它可以是基努。
It could be Keanu. Well, we need to find out if Keanu ever took improv class there. If he didn't, then it's definitely you. And Matthew Perry, my goodness. I have to say Matthew Perry also kind of looks like Kiana. But also kind of looks like Dwight. This is here. It's a way he's very pointed.
它可以是基努。好吧，我们需要查明基努是否在那里上过即兴表演课。如果他没有，那绝对是你。还有马修·佩里，天哪。我得说马修·佩里也长得有点像基努。但也有点像德怀特。这是在这里。这是一个他非常尖锐的。
You're right. It's got the shrewt part. The shrewt part. The shrewt part. Absolutely. Yeah. Well, there's a lot of artistic interpretation with this mural.
你是对的。有施鲁特的特征。施鲁特的特征。施鲁特的特征。绝对的。是的。好吧，这幅壁画有很多艺术解释。
Yes, there are. But anyway, big thanks to the only connection comedy theater. Well, before we a lot of artistic interpretation with this mural. Yes, there are. But anyway, big thanks to the LA Connection Comedy Theater. Well, before we let you go, will you tell us about Sweeney Todd? Are you going to be in Sweeney Todd until January 2024? I am. Yes, so this is a role that I've loved ever since I was a little, you know, baritone that couldn't dance and thought that's the role for me. I really, I love song times music.
是的，确实有很多。不管怎样，非常感谢洛杉矶连接喜剧剧院。好吧，在我们对这幅壁画有很多艺术解释之前。是的，确实有很多。不管怎样，非常感谢洛杉矶连接喜剧剧院。好吧，在我们让你离开之前，能给我们讲讲《理发师陶德》吗？你要一直演《理发师陶德》到2024年1月吗？是的。所以这是一个我从小就喜欢的角色，你知道，一个不会跳舞的男中音，觉得那就是适合我的角色。我真的，我热爱桑德姆的音乐。
You know, we all, everybody who's in this cast has loved this show since we were little to have the opportunity to bring it to Broadway in a really large revival has been a dream. So when Tommy Kailer, director, kind of said, hey, you know, if we're gonna do this, I really think we should think about like doing it, you know, really diving in and saying,
你知道，我们所有人都，这个剧组的每个人从小就喜欢这个剧，有机会以一种真正宏大的复排形式把它带到百老汇一直是一个梦想。所以当导演汤米·卡勒说，嘿，你知道，如果我们要做这个，我真的认为我们应该考虑真正深入进去，并说，
this is what we're gonna chisel for a year of work. And obviously it's a big commitment, but it's one that's been super worth it for me to dive into, we're having an amazing time. And it's also funny, like there's parts where the audience are just absolutely cracking up. There's dark humor in it. The music is some of the most extraordinary music
这就是我们要用一年的工作来雕琢的东西。显然这是一个巨大的承诺，但对我来说深入其中非常值得，我们度过了非常棒的时光。而且也很有趣，比如有些部分观众绝对会捧腹大笑。里面有黑色幽默。音乐是音乐剧中最非凡的音乐之一
that I've ever heard in musical theater. And it's a bloody good time. We're having a really good time. Very tired, but we're having a good time. I bet. I'm gonna be coming to see you in June. The next time I'm in New York, I'm gonna come see the show in June.
我听过的音乐剧音乐。而且这是一段非常棒的时光。我们过得很开心。非常累，但我们过得很开心。我敢说。我六月份要去看你。下次我去纽约时，我六月份要去看这个演出。
And I absolutely can't wait. It is at the top of my list. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. I did. We're not going anywhere. So good. So yeah. That gives me time to get to New York too. I don't have any plans to get to New York,
我绝对等不及了。这是我的首选。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我做了。我们哪儿也不去。太棒了。所以，是的。这给了我时间去纽约。我没有去纽约的计划，
but now I have a reason. So I'm going to figure out how to get there. Come on out. This has just been so wonderful. I definitely want anyone listening or office ladies fans. If you are in New York, please go see Josh and Swini Todd. And what a delight.
但我现在有了一个理由。所以我得想办法去那里。来吧。这真是太棒了。我绝对希望任何收听的听众或《办公室辣妈》的粉丝。如果你在纽约，请务必去看乔什演的《理发师陶德》。真是太开心了。
Oh my gosh, we're going to be talking about this interview for a bit. Yeah, thank you so much. Thank you for having me. Thank you for just the wonderful experience of being on set with you both. And thank you for so many years of much needed laughter and smiles and love. And I really appreciate you having me on. and Pam arriving to work because they saw Andy's new billboard. Yes, Pam arrives to work. Did you notice in pants? I didn't know. Finally, when you are eight months and three weeks pregnant, you get to wear pants. Well, Pam and her pants can't get over this billboard. And Jim's going to share that,
天哪，我们要讨论这个采访好一会儿了。是的，非常感谢。谢谢邀请我。谢谢你们带给我的在片场和你们在一起的美好经历。谢谢你们多年来带给我的急需的笑声、微笑和爱。我真的很感激你们邀请我上节目。和帕姆到达公司，因为他们看到了安迪的新广告牌。是的，帕姆到达公司。你注意到裤子了吗？我不知道。最后，当你怀孕八周零三周时，你终于可以穿裤子了。好吧，帕姆和她的裤子无法释怀这个广告牌。吉姆将分享，
you know what, if there's an opportunity for a graffiti artist to work in a phallic image into artwork, it's going to happen. And this is when we find out that all of the billboards have been defaced. Yes. Someone has put, I mean, how do you say it? Penises all over these billboards. Andy holds up pictures of what the billboards were before they had been defaced. He did a whole photo shoot with Dwight. Yeah. And you can see how one could add the penises.
你知道的，如果有机会让涂鸦艺术家在艺术品中融入阴茎形象，那是一定会发生的。这就是我们发现所有的广告牌都被涂污的时候。是的。有人画了，我是说，你怎么说呢？这些广告牌上到处都是阴茎。安迪举起照片，展示了广告牌被涂污之前的样子。他和德怀特拍了一整套照片。是的。你可以看到一个人怎么会加上阴茎。
Yes. In the shooting draft, the scene was described like this. We see B-roll, several billboard mockups. The first mockup features the slogan, new low prices, shout it from the rooftops, and shows Andy with a huge open mouth in his hands to the sides of his mouth yelling. The second mockup also has Andy with a wide open mouth. One arm to the sky, singing the slogan, low prices icing O.V. The third mockup shows Andy closing his eyes
是的。在拍摄初稿中，这一场景的描述如下：我们看到B面素材，几个广告牌样机。第一个样机以标语“全新低价，从屋顶大声喊出来”为特色，展示了安迪张着巨大的嘴巴，双手放在嘴边大喊。第二个样机同样是安迪张着大嘴。一只手臂伸向天空，唱着标语“低价冰激凌O.V”。第三个样机展示了安迪闭上眼睛，
and raising two fists diagonally towards him. Why are our prices so low? My favorite part of that explanation was your gestures, Angela, which I am the only one who gets to see. You're the only one who's been doing this, but I didn't even mean to do it as I was reading it. I just acted out what was happening. You sure did. So I want to say that I believe that the idea for this cold open was because of something
双拳向斜上方举起。为什么我们的价格这么低？我最喜欢那段解释的部分是你的手势，安吉拉，只有我一个人能看到。你是唯一一个一直在做这个的人，但我读的时候甚至不是故意要做的。我只是把发生的事情演出来了。你确实演出来了。所以我想说，我相信这个冷场开场（cold open）的想法是因为某件事
that happened to me in real life, that I told everyone in the conference room one day when we were shooting between scenes. This is what would happen. This is what would happen. You would share something from your life and all of a sudden it would end up in an episode. So here's what happened. Angel, you know I love tiny desserts. I know you do. You know I love a tiny little parfait cup, you know, it's in like the most like a little shot glass. It has a teeny tiny spoon. Tiny spoon, are you love it?
在现实生活中发生在我身上，有一天我们在场景之间拍摄时，我在会议室里把这件事告诉了所有人。这就是会发生的情况。这就是会发生的情况。你会分享你生活中的某件事，突然它就会出现在一集中。所以事情是这样的。安吉，你知道我喜欢迷你甜点。我知道你喜欢。你知道我喜欢一个迷你的小芭菲杯，你知道，它就像在一个小烈酒杯里。它有一个极小的勺子。极小的勺子，你超爱它？
Any tiny cupcake, like the tinyest cupcake ever. Like the size of your thumb. Yeah, like the kind that baked by Melissa does. They're just tiny. Oh, we love those. They're just a bite. So I was at an event and they had an itty bitty dessert with a tiny spoon and I took a picture for social media
任何迷你纸杯蛋糕，比如史上最小的纸杯蛋糕。就像你的拇指大小。是的，就像贝克·梅丽莎（Baked by Melissa）做的那种。它们就是很小。哦，我们超爱那些。它们只是一口大小。所以我在一个活动上，他们有一个带有小勺的小型甜点，我为社交媒体拍了一张照片，
where I was holding up a little dessert in one hand. In the other hand, I had my mouth open and it was like I was pretending to put the little spoon in my mouth. Mistake. Eh eh eh. Yeah. Guess what someone did with that picture?
照片里我一只手拿着小甜点。另一只手我张着嘴，就像我假装把小勺放进嘴里一样。大错特错。呃呃呃。是的。你猜有人对那张照片做了什么？
Well. Basically the cold open. Yeah. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Well. Basically, the cold open. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Mm-hmm. And we were in the conference room, and that's when I swear I can't remember who it was, but one of our cast members was like, Jenna,
好吧。基本上就是冷场开场。是的。是的。嗯哼。好吧。基本上就是冷场开场。是的。是的，是的。嗯哼。我们在会议室里，然后我发誓我记不清是谁了，但我们的一个演员说，珍妮，
didn't anyone ever tell you? You never post a photo of yourself with an open mouth because someone will put a dick in it. I was like, no, I didn't know. I have such a problem with her. I wish someone had told me. I remembered this happening in the conference room and we were all like, no, I didn't. I have someone who told me. I remember this opening in the conference room and we were all like, what?
难道没人告诉你吗？你绝不能发布自己张着嘴的照片，因为会有人在里面塞个鸡巴。我当时想，不，我不知道。我对她有这么大的问题。我希望有人告诉我。我记得这件事发生在会议室里，我们都觉得，不，我不知道。我有个人告诉我。我记得这个开场发生在会议室里，我们都觉得，什么？
And they were like, the half of the room had never heard of this. And the other half were like, duh. Yeah. It savvy. Yeah. And so thus, I believe is the inspiration for this cold open.
然后他们说，房间里的一半人从未听说过这个。另一半人则觉得，废话。是的。很懂行。是的。因此，我相信这就是这个冷场开场的灵感来源。
Well, we got some fan questions about it. Lila C and Chicago said, were the billboards in the cold open CGI or were they actually put up and did rain and ed have a photo shoot for them? Well, Steve Burgess said that we did have a photo shoot with rain and ed and we did shoot like toward a billboard.
好吧，我们收到了一些关于它的粉丝问题。芝加哥的莉拉·C说，冷场开场中的广告牌是CGI制作的，还是真的竖起来了，雷恩和埃德为它们拍过照片吗？好吧，史蒂夫·伯格斯说我们确实和雷恩和埃德拍过照片，我们确实对着一个广告牌拍了。
It was near Disney Ranch, which is where we shot shoot farms, but we didn't actually put the photo up on the billboard. We did just CGI that. So rain runs around a corner and looks at like an empty billboard, and then we put the image CGI on it. Yeah, luckily for Ed and Rain, those billboards and everyone up. That's right. We got another fan question from Kelly S.
它在迪士尼牧场附近，也就是我们拍摄施鲁特农场的地方，但我们并没有真正把照片挂在广告牌上。我们只是用CGI制作了那个。所以雷恩跑过一个拐角，看着一个空广告牌，然后我们用CGI把图像放了上去。是的，幸运的是对埃德和雷恩来说，那些广告牌和每个人都在上面。没错。我们收到了来自凯利·S的另一个粉丝问题。
In New Hampshire, who said, I need a standards and practices deep dive on this cold open. Oh, I have so many questions. You are not going to believe this. Do you remember when I said that I feel like there was a giant tonal shift between the way standards and practices treated Randy Cordray and the way they treated Steve Burgess? Yeah, there's no more as previously stated. Listen to this, this is all they wrote.
新罕布什尔州的凯利说，我需要对这个冷场开场进行一次标准与实践（Standards and Practices）的深度剖析。哦，我有太多问题了。你绝对不会相信这个。还记得我说过我觉得标准与实践对待兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）的方式和对待史蒂夫·伯格斯的方式之间存在巨大的基调转变吗？是的，没有更多的“如前所述”了。听听这个，这就是他们写的所有内容。
This is what Steve said. This is the only note they got about this whole, cold open. It said this quote, as always, we trust the pixelation we'll cover what was drawn on the billboard. We trust. We trust you. Wow. You'll do it right. I can't wait for the first lip flap. I want to know how that email goes. I don't think they're ever going to lip flap Steve Birch's. I don't know. They're like, it'll be fine.
这就是史蒂夫所说的话。这是他们关于整个沉浸式开场得到的唯一的便签。上面写着，就像往常一样，我们信任像素化，我们会覆盖广告牌上画的内容。我们信任。我们信任你们。哇。你们会做好的。我等不及看第一张嘴唇翻动了。我想知道那封邮件是怎么回事。我觉得他们永远不会去给史蒂夫·伯奇的嘴唇翻动。我不知道。他们大概觉得，会没事的。
Suddenly they're so okay. Oh my gosh. Well now we're ready for the actual episode to start. There's a conference room scene and Dwight has an elaborate map that he has drawn on a dry erase board of how to get to Shrute Farms. He doesn't want anyone googling how to get there. Just please follow the map. He's drawn. What is it with Dwight in random directions? Do you remember when Dwight gave Andi and Angela directions to Shrute Farms?
突然间他们就这么觉得没问题了。噢，天哪。好吧，现在我们准备好让正片开始了。有一个会议室场景，德怀特在白板上画了一张详细的地图，说明如何去舒鲁特农场。他不想让任何人谷歌搜索怎么去那里。请务必照着地图走。这是他画的。德怀特怎么总有这么多奇奇怪怪的路线？还记得德怀特给安迪和安吉拉指路去舒鲁特农场的时候吗？
He's determined to make it wonky. And before we get into Shrut farms and arrive there, Jenna, I have some stuff from my digital clutter about Shrut farms. Uh-huh. Oh, please share. I have an email from Steve Burgess that he sent Sunday evening, August 4, 2011. Subject, Shrute Farms location. High team office, a couple of safety notes for our Garden Party shoot at Shrute Farms. First and foremost, it will be hot. Please drink plenty of water and orgatorade or coconut water in parentheses for electrolytes.
他铁了心要把路线搞得古怪。在我们进入舒鲁特农场并到达那里之前，珍娜，我有一些关于舒鲁特农场的数字杂物。嗯哼。哦，请分享一下。我有一封史蒂夫·伯吉斯于2011年8月4日星期日晚上发出的邮件。主题，舒鲁特农场位置。各位办公室团队成员，关于我们在舒鲁特农场拍摄花园派对的一些安全注意事项。首先也是最重要的一点，天气会很热。请多喝水和百得力或椰子水（括号内指为了电解质）。
I hate coconut water. I just think it's like, what? Yeah! Oh my God! If you become this person for coconut water, there's cause that dream. Oh my God. I think it tastes like...
我讨厌椰子水。我只是觉得这就像，什么？耶！噢，天哪！如果你成了这种推崇椰子水的人，那就是因为那个梦。噢，天哪。我觉得它的味道就像……
We know what you... Okay, fine. We don't have to say it twice. Why are you doubling down on this? Do you disagree if you drink warm coconut water? You'll never untaste it again. No, I don't want to drink warm coconut water. You don't because it tastes like... Oh my You don't because it tastes like a real one.
我们知道你……好吧，好吧。我们不用说两遍。你为什么在这个问题上态度这么强硬？如果你喝温椰子水，你不同意吗？你再也忘不掉那个味道了。不，我不想喝温椰子水。你不想喝是因为它尝起来像……哦，天哪。你不想喝是因为它尝起来就像真的一样。
Not when someone sees you. Oh my god. What a taste like. I don't even know where to go from here. With Steve Burgess's very sweet, fatherly email, just wanting us to stay hydrated. Oh my god. Well, let's see.
不是当别人看着你的时候。哦，天哪。尝起来像什么。我都不知道从哪接话了。带着史蒂夫·伯吉斯那封非常甜蜜、充满父爱、只想让我们保持水分的邮件。哦，天哪。好吧，让我们看看。
I will continue to read this email. Let's see if it sparks any other strong feelings. Patrice, who is our set medic, also will have electrolyte packs that you can add to your water bottle. It will help if you, and then he put in bold lettering, drink plenty of water, starting the day before. And that is today for most of us. Steve really wanted to make sure we were hydrated. He emailed us on Sunday saying, start drinking water now.
我将继续阅读这封邮件。看看它是否能引发其他强烈的情感。帕特里斯，我们的片场医务人员，也将备有电解质包，你可以把它加到你的水瓶里。如果你能做到以下这点会很有帮助——然后他用粗体字写道——从前一天开始，多喝水。对于我们大多数人来说，今天就是那一天。史蒂夫真的很想确保我们补充了水分。他在周日给我们发邮件说，现在就开始喝水。
That's how hot it's gonna be. Wow, he told us to drink water in like four different ways. Oh, it continues. If you begin to feel the effects of the heat, headaches, and or dizziness, or nausea, please let us know immediately. Now, here's the second part. There are bees at this location.
天气会有多热，可想而知。哇，他用大约四种不同的方式让我们喝水。哦，邮件还在继续。如果你开始感到中暑的症状，头痛和/或头晕，或恶心，请立即通知我们。现在，是第二部分。这个地方有蜜蜂。
If you know you're allergic to bees, please let us know and bring your epipen. Bees are also attracted to some perfumes and colognes. Please refrain from wearing them at this location. Wow! So, not only were we going to have to start hydrating the day before, but also no one smelled probably very good on this shoot. It goes on. Please read the rules and regulations for Disney's Golden Oak Ranch.
如果你知道自己对蜜蜂过敏，请告诉我们并带上你的肾上腺素笔。蜜蜂也很容易被一些香水和古龙水吸引。请在这个地方避免使用它们。哇！所以，我们不仅得在前一天开始补充水分，而且这次拍摄时可能谁闻起来都不会太好。邮件接着说。请阅读迪士尼金橡树牧场的规章制度。
They are attached to the call sheet. There will be no visitors allowed, no exceptions. Thank you. Let's have a safe and productive week, Steve. Then you forwarded me his email and you added this to it, Jenna. Okay. Apparently you had worked already a day there
它们附在通告单上。谢绝访客，绝无例外。谢谢。让我们度过一个安全且富有成效的一周，史蒂夫。然后你把他的邮件转发给我，并在上面加了这些内容，珍娜。好的。显然你已经在那儿工作了一天了
before I arrived. Okay. You wrote, lady, he's serious about the bees. They are everywhere. They got all in the food at lunch. Oh, and there are snakes like for real. We have a snake wrangler on set. Rain said the last time he was here,
在我到达之前。好的。你写道，女士，他对蜜蜂是认真的。它们到处都是。午餐时它们全爬到食物里去了。哦，还有蛇，真的有蛇。我们片场有专门的抓蛇人。雷恩说他上次来这儿的时候，
they actually had to remove a rattlesnake from the set. So don't walk in any tall grass, stick to the path. Good luck, I'm off tomorrow. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, it's funny, Angela.
他们真的从片场抓走了一条响尾蛇。所以不要走在任何高高的草丛里，沿着小路走。祝你好运，我明天休息。好的。好的。好的。好的。好吧，有趣的是，安吉拉。
I had a special meeting with Steve Burgess before we got to Shrewt Farms because I was very Really pregnant? Yes, you emailed me it as well. I did. Yes. There was a lot of extra safety precautions that they took for me because they were very worried about me getting overheated Yes, you sent me an email that you're like, hey Steve and I are trading emails about how to keep me cool and not get too hot because I'm eight and a half months pregnant, which is one of the reasons, and I'm going to bring it up. There is a deleted scene that you and I filmed inside just me and you so that we can be cool. Oh, good. I'm so glad you're going to share. Well, Angela, I don't know what I love more.
在到达舒鲁特农场之前，我和史蒂夫·伯吉斯开了一个特别会议，因为我当时非常……真的很怀孕？是的，你也把这封邮件发给我了。我是发了。是的。为了我，他们采取了许多额外的安全预防措施，因为他们非常担心我会中暑。是的，你给我发了一封邮件，说“嘿，史蒂夫和我正在发邮件讨论怎么让我保持凉爽、不要太热”，因为我怀孕八个半月了，这也是原因之一，我要提一下。有一个被删减的场景是你和我只在室内拍的，只有我和你，这样我们可以凉快点。哦，太好了。我很高兴你要分享这个。好吧，安吉拉，我不知道我更喜欢哪个。
Dwight's description of how to get to Shrewt Farms or the email you got from Steve Burgess telling us how to survive Shrute Farms. They're both pretty delicious. The folks in the conference room would like to know, why are we having this party? What is the reason? What is the reason? Yeah. You don't need a reason for a garden party. It's like a birthday party. Yes, however, Andy is going to tell you there are rules to a garden party. Many, many rules, including how to dress, how to eat, how to behave, but it's, you know, it's going to be fun. It's casual. It's for no reason.
德怀特关于如何去舒鲁特农场的描述，还是你收到的来自史蒂夫·伯吉斯的、教我们如何在舒鲁特农场生存的邮件。它们都挺精彩的。会议室里的各位想知道，我们为什么要办这个派对？理由是什么？理由是什么？是的。办花园派对不需要理由。就像生日派对一样。是的，然而，安迪要告诉你，花园派对是有规矩的。有很多很多的规矩，包括怎么穿衣、怎么吃东西、怎么表现，但是，你知道的，这会很有趣。这很休闲。没有理由。
Well, we find out pretty quickly that not only our Andy's parents going to be there, and it's clear that he wants to have a moment with them and impress them, and also Robert California's invited. Yes, it's during this scene that Andy also pulls out his laptop to show us a video of a recent garden party that his family threw for his brother, Walter Jr. And it's very sweet. Walter Jr. and his dad are harmonizing. They're singing together.
好吧，我们很快发现，不仅安迪的父母会出席——显然他想在他们面前表现一番并给他们留下好印象——而且罗伯特·加利福尼亚也被邀请了。是的，正是在这场戏里，安迪还拿出了他的笔记本电脑，给我们看了一段他家人最近为他弟弟小沃尔特举办的花园派对的视频。非常温馨。小沃尔特和他的爸爸在进行和声。他们在一起唱歌。
Walter Jr's boss is there looking on, impressed, and poor Andy's in the background. He's very jealous. We had a fan catch from Jennifer M. in Portland, Texas. Jennifer has been writing into us every week, Angela, about every episode. Ever since we shared that we had to digitally remove all of the Apple logos from the computers in the episode
小沃尔特的上司在一旁看着，印象深刻，而可怜的安迪站在背景里。他非常嫉妒。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州波特兰的詹妮弗·M.的粉丝来信。詹妮弗每周都会给我们的每一集写信，安吉拉。自从我们分享了在埃琳得到新电脑那一集里，我们不得不把电脑上的所有苹果标志都用数字技术抹掉之后，詹妮弗就一直在追踪苹果标志，因为显然我们不再把它们数字抹掉了。她提到安迪的笔记本电脑上有一个。詹妮弗，你就是苹果标志的博士。是的，好眼力。会议在德怀特提醒大家切勿谷歌搜索如何前往舒鲁特农场中结束。
where Erin gets a new computer, Jennifer has been tracking the Apple logos because apparently we stopped digitizing them out. And she mentioned that there is one here on Andy's laptop. Jennifer, you are the doctor of the Apple logos. Yes, nice catch. The meeting ends with Dwight reminding everyone to please not Google how to get to Shrute Farms.
当然，吉姆的反应是：为什么德怀特非要强调这个？他在搞什么鬼？所以吉姆谷歌搜索了舒鲁特农场，你猜他发现了什么。他找到了舒鲁特农场的街景照片，你猜他找到了什么。他找到了舒鲁特农场的街景照片，那是莫斯和德怀特在玩跷跷板。赤裸着上身在玩跷跷板。是的。德怀特说，你永远不知道他们什么时候会开车路过。好吧，这是对《经理与推销员》一集的呼应。
And of course, Jim is like, why is Dwight pushing this? What's he up to? So Jim, Google's Shrute Farms and guess what he finds. He finds the Street View photo of Shrute Farms and guess what he finds. He finds the Street View photo of Shrute Farms, which is a mose and dweye on a seasaw. Shirtless on a seasaw. Yeah. Dwight's like, you never know when they're going to drive by. Well, this was a callback to manager and salesmen.
还记得莱恩和德怀特在垃圾箱旁时，莱恩说，你玩过跷跷板吗？对此德怀特的回答是，是的，莫斯和我……在垃圾箱旁时，莱恩说，你看过《电锯惊魂》吗？对此德怀特的回答是，是的，莫斯和我经常玩跷跷板。是的，这是对那一集的呼应。莱恩说的是，你看过电影《电锯惊魂》吗？那部电影。是的。德怀特要分享的是，他一直想打入高端活动行业
Do you remember when Ryan and Dwight are out by the dumpsters and Ryan is like, did you ever seasaw? To which Dwight replies, yes, mose and I se are out by the dumpsters and Ryan is like, did you ever see Saw? To which Dwight replies, yes, Mose and I see Saw all the time. Yes, this was a callback to that episode. Ryan is saying, did you see Saw the movie? The movie. Yes. Dwight is going to share that he has always wanted to break into the high event industry
为舒鲁特农场。所以他对这个派对非常兴奋。这对他是绝佳的机会。不仅如此，他还找到了一本书。世上仅此一本的关于如何策划完美花园派对的书。作者是詹姆斯·特里金顿。是的，他只花了2美元就买到了。唯一的副本。
for Shrute Farm. So he's very excited about this party. This is a great opportunity for him. Not only that, he found a book. There was only one in existence about how to plan the perfect garden party. It's by James Trichington. Yeah, he got it for only $2. The only copy.
他特意强调了这一点。他要严格按照书上的每一个字来打造这个惊艳的花园派对。好吧，吉姆有一个独白，你猜詹姆斯·特里金顿是谁？哦，我猜是谁，不就是吉姆嘛。拜托，德怀特。拜托。还有，吉姆，你的空闲时间都在干嘛？你在写书？
He makes that clear. And he's going to follow it to the letter on how to make this amazing garden party. Well, Jim has a talking head, and guess who James Trickington is? Oh, I wonder who it's Jim. Come on, Dwight. Come on. Also, Jim, what do you do with your free time? You're writing a book?
第九章。最终，我们知道一共有九章。女士。女士。女士。粉丝来信狂潮。我太高兴了，因为我写了这段。这对我来说可能是吉姆搞过的最大的一场恶作剧了。他整整写了一本书。
Chapter 9. Eventually, we know there's nine chapters. Lady. Lady. Lady. Fan mail flurry. I'm so glad because I wrote this. This may be the biggest Jim prank stretch for me. He wrote a whole book.
搞什么鬼？好吧，来自加拿大特里蒙塔里奥的莉娅·A.、来自德克萨斯州的Maddie K.、来自纽约的布兰登以及许多其他人这么说。吉姆在一周的通知时间内写完整本书，出版了一本副本，并确保它落入德怀特手中，这难道从来没有被质疑过有点太不现实了吗？吉姆是不是设法精准投放广告，笃定德怀特会找到并买下它？演员和剧组
What the hell? Well, Lee A. Tremontario, Canada, Maddie K. from Texas, Brandon from New York, and many others said this. Was it ever questioned that Jim writing an entire book with what? A week's notice, getting one copy published and making sure it wound up in Dwight's hands was a little too unrealistic? Did Jim somehow manage to target advertise it knowing that Dwight would find it and buy it? Did the cast and crew
对此有什么感觉吗？好吧各位，我告诉你们谁有同样的感受。迈尔斯·麦克纳特。哦，迈尔斯，拜托，我得听听他对这件事的看法。首先，他给这一集打了C分。哦，你算老几？这也是他的最大槽点之一。他提出了一个问题，真的没有关于办花园派对的书吗？好吧，你猜怎么着？我查过了。我敢打赌这种书有的是。我猜玛莎·斯图尔特至少写过一本。我也这么想。
feel this way at all? Well everyone, I'll tell you who felt the same way. Miles McNut. Oh, Miles, please, I need to hear his thoughts on this. Well, first of all, he gave this episode a C. Oh, who are you? And this was one of his biggest gripes. He asked the question, are there really no books about throwing a garden party? Well, guess what? I looked it up. I bet there are so many. I'm going to guess Martha Stewart has done at least one. I thought the same thing.
你猜怎么着？我找不到任何一本名为《如何办花园派对》或关于办花园派对的书。不，一本也没有。你知道为什么吗？为什么？因为这不是一本书。你知道为什么吗？为什么？因为这不是一本书。它是一本小册子。
Guess what? I could not find a single book called How to Throw a Garden Party or about throwing a garden party. No, not a one. You know why? Why? Because this is not a one. You know why? Why? Because this is not a book. It's a pamphlet.
它可能只有文章的四页纸。我是说，听我讲，我找到了很多派对策划书籍，里面包含了关于花园场景的一章，但没有一本是专门写花园派对的书。不过，在亚马逊上，我确实找到了几个版本的詹姆斯·特里金顿的书。有一本售价7.95美元，实际上是一个周历记事本，但它的封面和你在剧中看到的一模一样。
It may be four pages in an article. I mean, listen, there's lots of party planning books that include a chapter on a garden setting that I found, but there is not a book dedicated to the garden party. However, on Amazon, I did find several versions of James Trickington's book. There is one for $7.95 that is actually a weekly planner, but it has the same cover as the one you see in the episode.
还有一本售价20美元左右，里面包含剧中的台词摘录和写日记的页面。接下来，我们在休息室里有一些重磅恶作剧和小型恶作剧。是的，帕姆和安吉拉在那儿。安吉拉在吃一碗葡萄。帕姆在用特百惠饭盒吃带香蕉和一些薯片的酸奶。我做了一个食物成分分析。不错。安吉拉说她的胸部大了一个罩杯。
And there is another one for around $20 that includes quotes from the show and pages for journaling. Up next, we have some big pricks, little pricks in the break room. Yes, Pam and Angela are in there. Angela is eating a bowl of grapes. Pam is eating yogurt out of a Tupperware container of banana and some chips. I did a food breakdown. Nice. Angela says her breasts have gone up a bra size.
这让参议员觉得很恶心。在这段来回的对话中，帕姆一不小心说出了她儿子的名字。她说，菲利普。是的。安吉拉说，等等，等等，等等。菲利普是我给我的宝宝起的名字。帕姆说，我给菲利普起这个名字是为了纪念我的祖父。安吉拉说，嗯，我给我的宝宝起这个名字是为了纪念我的猫。
It's grossing out the senator. This back and forth conversation, Pam is going to slip and say the name of her son. She says, Philip. Yes. And angels like, wait, wait, wait. Philip is what I'm naming my baby. And Pam's like, I'm naming Philip after my grandfather. And Angel says, well, I'm naming my baby after my cat.
她最喜欢的猫。她最喜欢的猫。这对她来说分量是一样的。她最喜欢的猫。她最喜欢的猫。这对她来说分量是一样的。她最喜欢的猫和帕姆的祖父。所以帕姆和安吉拉都决定给她们的宝宝起名叫菲利普，这其实让我想起了我家里发生过的一件事。当我的爸爸妈妈怀着我姐姐蒂娜时，我爸爸的姐姐也怀孕了，怀着一个小女孩。
Her favorite cat. Her favorite cat. These have the same weight to her. Her favorite cat. Her favorite cat. These have the same weight to her. Her favorite cat in Pam's grandfather. So Pam and Angela both decided to name their baby's Philip actually reminded me of something that happened with my family. When my mom and dad were having my sister Tina, my dad's sister was also pregnant, having a little girl.
他们住在不同的州。那是互联网或社交媒体出现之前，人们不会经常互相问候。他们当时并不知情，但他们都选了“蒂娜”这个名字。而且她们都给自己的女儿取名叫蒂娜。什么？是的。所以你有一个姐姐和一个表妹，名字都叫蒂娜，而且她们是差不多同一时间出生的。
And they lived states apart. This was before the internet or social media when people were always checking in with each other. They did not know it, but they had both picked the name Tina. And they both named their daughters Tina. What? Yes. So you have a sister and a cousin, both named Tina, and they were born around the same time.
前后只差14个小时，同一个家族里出生了两个蒂娜，只差14个小时。我一辈子都没把这当回事，因为他们从来没有把这当成什么大事。然后当我怀孕了，我们在努力挑选一个婴儿名字时，我说，哦，天哪，妈妈。路易丝阿姨和爸爸都生了女儿并且都取名叫蒂娜。我说，妈妈，你知道她说什么吗？她说，哦，这个世界足够大，容得下两个蒂娜，你知道的。是的，这真是一个绝佳的视角。你知道，如果你和某人
Within 14 hours of each other, two Tina's and the same family born 14 hours apart. And I never thought anything about it my whole life because they never made a big thing about it. And then when I was pregnant and we were trying to pick a baby name, I was like, oh my gosh, mom. Aunt Louise and dad both had daughters and named them Tina. And I was like, mom, and you know what she said? She goes, oh, and the world is big enough for two Tina's, you know, yeah, it was such great perspective. You know, if you and someone
都喜欢同一个婴儿名字，这个世界足够大，容得下两个名字。只要让他们平平安安、健健康康地来到这个世界。这才是最重要的。确实如此。好吧，接下来是我最喜欢的场景之一。詹姆士·巴德太厉害了，他的演技仅仅通过一个电话就能完全展现出来，因为罗伯特·加利福尼亚给安迪打电话，提到他今天下午有两个可能的伴手礼选择。这是一场极其诡异的对话。确实是。他分享说他有一罐橘子酱和一盆罗勒。他显然想让安迪选择罗勒。他一直在极力推销罗勒。为什么还要提橘子酱？听着，他跟他的姐姐提过橘子酱，她非常想要。然后他冲着助理大喊，再拿一罐橘子酱来，因为安迪显然想要橘子酱。我太喜欢了。我看了这一幕。我倒回去又看了一遍，因为它把我逗笑了。光是他的声音演技就够了。我知道。
else, both like the same baby name, the world's big enough for both of them. Just get them here safe and healthy. That's all that matters. That's true. Well, next up is one of my favorite scenes. James Bader is so good that his acting comes through in just a phone call because Robert California is going to call Andy on the phone and mention that he has two possible host gifts for this afternoon. This is such a bizarre conversation. It is. He shares that he has a pot of marmalade and a basil plant. He clearly wants Andy to choose the basil plant. He's really pushing the basil plant. Why even bring up the marmalade? Listen, he mentioned the marmalade to his sister and she really wants it. And then he shouts at his assistant to get a second
人们现在正抵达舒鲁特农场参加派对。托比把车开过来，代客泊车员是莫斯。他跑向托比，说我得开走你的车。托比说，不，然后他们发生了拉扯。莫斯赢了，开着车走了。拉扯，他把一只脚踩在车后备箱上，强行把车门打开，然后开车逃跑，他加速逃走了。非常具有攻击性的代客泊车员。
jar of marmalade because Andy clearly wants the Marmalade. I loved it. I watched this scene. I backed it up and watched it again because it made me laugh. Just his voice acting. I know. People are arriving now to Shrute Farms for the party. Toby pulls up and the valet is mose.
我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯的粉丝阿莉娅·G.的问题，她说：我写信是想问关于这一集中迈克尔·舒尔扮演的莫斯的问题。在6分32秒时，那句台词“祝你在派对上玩得开心”是他即兴发挥的吗？每次看到这我都笑得不行，我很想知道。好吧，我查过了，剧本里没有这句台词。莫斯加速逃走也不是剧本里的。相反，剧本里写的是他把车倒进拐角处，然后开车冲过一片玉米地，
He runs up to him and he's like, I have to take your car. And Toby's like, no, and then they have this struggle. And Mo's wins and drives off in his car. Struggle, he puts his foot up on the back of the car and is like forcing the door open and then drives away, he speeds away. Very aggressive valet.
碾倒了一排玉米秆。他在一个随机的地点停下，下车，然后把车留在那里。太棒了。开车冲进地里那个人不是迈克尔·舒尔吧？我觉得开车冲进玉米秆里的人不是他，但加速逃走的那个人应该是他。是的，我是说，镜头没有切。他上车然后加速开走了，但后来我觉得冲进真的玉米秆里的人不是他。我太好奇了。凯文要到了。他戴着他的假发。不错的呼应。凯莉和埃琳都戴着小礼帽。德怀特在大家到达时大声喊着每个人的名字。
We had a fan question from Alia G and Santa Cruz, California, who said I'm writing to ask about Mike sure as Mose in this episode. At six minutes and 32 seconds, did he improvise the line, have a good time at the thing? This cracks me up every time and I would love to know. Well, I looked it up, It was not in the script. It was also not in the script that most speeds away. Instead, the script said he backs the car around the corner and then drives the car through a cornfield,
吉姆有一个独白说，宣布客人的到来是礼仪的最高境界，声音越大，给予的荣誉就越高。他在他的书里写过这个，女士。这是他书的一部分，德怀特正严格遵循这些规则。你可能注意到，当吉姆和帕姆到达时，他们被宣布为帕梅拉·詹姆斯和P.P.·赫尔珀特。这是雷恩即兴发挥的一个呼应。剧本里只是简单地说他嘟囔着说出了婴儿的名字。所以他本该说，詹姆斯、帕梅拉和米娜·赫尔珀特。但如果你还记得的话，德怀特在《搜寻委员会》中把他们的女儿叫作P.P.，雷恩·威尔逊这里呼应了这个梗。干得好，雷恩。好吧，奥斯卡
mowing down a row of stalks. At a random spot, he stops, gets out, and leaves it. Amazing. It wasn't Mike sure driving that car into that field, was it? I don't think it was him driving into the cornstalks, but I think it's him speeding away. Yeah, I mean, there's no cut. He gets in the car and speeds away, but later I don't think that's him going into the actual stocks. I was so curious. Kevin is going to arrive. He's rocking his toupee. Nice callback. Kelly and Aaron have their fascinators on. And Dwight starts yelling everyone's name as they arrive.
对安迪的寸步不离感到厌烦，安迪对奥斯卡说，我希望一切都好，梅贝尔，你觉得呢？梅贝尔，梅贝尔，如果你行的话，把手肘离开桌子。嗯。这让我很好奇。拍摄初稿里还有其他安迪的餐桌礼仪名言吗，珍娜，还真有。真的吗。嗯哼。这段在被删减片段里。凯文拿了太多开胃小菜，安迪走过去对他说，
Jim has a talking head that says announcing guest arrival is the height of decorum, the more volume, the more honor bestowed. He's written this in his book, lady. This is part of his book, and Dwight is following the rules. You might have noticed that when Jim and Pam arrive, they are announced as Pamela James and P.P. Helpert. This was a callback that was improvised by Rain. In the script, it simply said that he mumbles the baby's name. So he would have said, James, Pamela, and Minna Helpert. But if you remember, Dwight called their daughter P.P. in search committee, and Rain Wilson called it back. Nice, Rain. Well, Oscar
凯文，这让我想起了我小时候学过的一个非常无趣、毫无用处的说法。开胃小菜和诺亚方舟上的动物有什么区别？对于开胃小菜，我们一次只拿一个。哦，太棒了。安迪的生活里有这么多的规矩。好吧，你猜怎么着？
is annoyed by Andy's hovering, and Andy says to Oscar, I want everything to be nice, that okay with you, Mabel? Mabel, Mabel, if you're able, keep your elbows off the table. Hmm. This made me curious. Were there other Andy etiquette sayings in the shooting draft and Jenner there were? Really. Mm-hmm. This one's in deleted scenes. Kevin is taking way too many appetizers, and Andy walks up to him and says,
安迪一直在等待的人终于到了。德怀特非常大声地宣布沃尔特和埃伦·伯纳德的到来。当雷恩扮演的德怀特大喊他们的名字时，我觉得饰演埃伦的女演员的反应太棒了。太棒了。整个人都懵了。就像，发生什么事了？是的。扮演安迪妈妈埃伦的是D·华莱士。史蒂夫·伯吉斯以前和她合作过，非常高兴能请她重回剧组。
Kevin, this totally reminds me of this really lame, useful saying, I learned as a kid. What's the difference between hors d'oeuvres and the animals on Noah's Ark? With hors d'oeuvres, we only take one at a time. Oh, amazing. So many rules in Andy's life. Well, guess what?
安吉拉，我认识D，不是私下认识，而是因为她主演了那么多经典的恐怖片，她是恐怖片女王级别的。我太喜欢她了。哦，我不知道。她出演过1977年原版的《隔山有眼》。她演过《嚎叫》、《狂犬库乔》、《魔精》、《月光光心慌慌》、《死亡之屋》。
The people Andy has been waiting for have arrived. Dwight very loudly announces the arrival of Walter and Ellen Bernard. When Rain is Dwight yelled their names, I thought the actress that played Ellen's reaction was so great. So good. So thrown off. Like, what is happening? Yes. D Wallace is who played Andy's mom, Ellen. Steve Burgess worked with her before and was so excited to have her back on the show.
她最著名的角色大概是在《E.T.外星人》中扮演妈妈。是的，是的，我就是这样认识D的。是的，哦，还有《狂犬库乔》，我记得《狂犬库乔》吓死我了。是的，她在接受《今夜娱乐》采访时说，她非常热爱演恐怖片，我觉得这真的很有趣。她说，如果她只能在喜剧或者别的什么单一领域发展，那会无聊透顶。这太搞笑了，因为她在这一集里演得太好了。是的。她的一举一动都极其微妙，
Angela, I know D, not personally, but because she has starred in so many classic horror films, she has like a horror queen. I love her. Oh, I didn't know. She was in the original 1977 The Hills Have Eyes. She was in the Howling, Kujo, Critters, Halloween, Death House.
我的目光根本无法从她身上移开。我觉得她表现得太精彩了。然后，扮演老沃尔特的斯蒂芬·柯林斯。他因在《第七天堂》中扮演父亲而非常著名，那部剧他拍了11季。我从来没看过《第七天堂》。我也没有。我错过了。
She is probably most famous for playing the mom in ET. Yes, yes, that's how I know D. Yes, oh, yeah. And also Kujo, I remember Kujo scared the crap out of me. Yes She said in an interview with entertainment tonight that she absolutely loves doing horror roles and this was I thought really funny She said that if she had to have a career like just in comedy or something it would just be so boring Which is so funny because she is so good in this episode. Yeah. Everything about her is so subtle,
但问题是。我想我得说，你可能听说过2014年关于斯蒂芬的一些新闻。我不知道该怎么委婉地表达这件事。我知道很多人带着孩子一起听播客。是的。所以请允许我这样说，2014年，斯蒂芬站出来承认了他过去一些非常令人不安的行为。如果你谷歌搜索他，这是跳出来的第一条
and I couldn't take my eyes off her. I thought she was fantastic. And then, Stephen Collins is who played Walter Senior. He is very famous for playing the dad on 7th Heaven, which he was on for 11 seasons. I have never seen 7th heaven. I had not either. I missed it.
内容。我可能不想在这里涉及太多细节，但只是想提一下。这发生在我们和他拍完戏很久之后，但是的，这挺令人沮丧的。好吧。我就说这么多。好吧。安吉拉，我们还收到了粉丝来信狂潮，许多人写信指出这些人并不是我们在托比的欢送派对上见到的那些人。没错。当安迪向安吉拉求婚时，是的，镜头切到他的父母，他们根本不是同一个演员。他们的名字也不一样。他们被介绍为埃伦和安德鲁·伯纳德，而不是埃伦和沃尔特·伯纳德。
But here is the thing. I guess I need to say you might be aware of some news that came out about Stephen in 2014. I don't know how to say this delicately. I know a lot of people listen to the podcast with their kids. Yes. So let me just say that in 2014 Stephen came forward and admitted to some pretty disturbing behavior in his past. If you Google him, it's the very first thing
现在，你知道的，我们有剧集圣经，里面记录了每个角色的背景、历史和起源故事。这怎么会发生呢？在我们向托比好好道别之后，我们在后来的某一集里开了一个非常搞笑的玩笑：安迪说他本名叫沃尔特，他是随父亲的名字起名的。但后来当他的弟弟出生时，他们把他重新命名为安迪，然后把小弟弟叫做小沃尔特。
that comes up. I don't want to maybe get into too many details here, but did just want to mention that. It was long after we had filmed with him, but yeah, it's upsetting. Okay. I'll leave it at that. Okay. We also Angela got a fan mail flurry of people writing in to point out that these are not the people we met at Toby's going away party. Right. When Andy proposes to Angela, yes, it cuts to his parents and they are not the same actors. They also do not have the same names. They are introduced as Ellen and Andrew Bernard, not Ellen and Walter Bernard.
所以这是一个有点违背向托比道别那一幕的笑话，但它太搞笑了。有时，当某个梗对他们来说真的很好笑时，他们就会违背剧集圣经。他们的态度是：喜剧第一，剧集圣经靠后。但我想要分享一个非常有趣的粉丝理论，由来自伊利诺伊州奥罗拉的伊娃·S.寄给我们的。我太喜欢了。我们来看。伊娃说，这些年来，关于安迪·伯纳德的家庭，我们了解到了许多古怪且明显相互矛盾的事情，以至于我想出了一个自认为能把这一切串联起来的解释。我们来看。安迪是沃尔特和埃伦·伯纳德的儿子，正如我们在这一集里了解到的那样。他们偏爱他的弟弟，对安迪则在情感上比较冷漠。
Now, you know, we have the show Bible where you have everyone's character and their history and their origin story. How did this happen? Well, after we did good by Toby, we had this very funny joke in a later episode where Andy says that his original name was Walter, that he was named after his dad. But then later when his younger brother was born, they renamed him Andy and then called his little brother Walter Jr.
他在对来自家庭的温暖爱意和接纳的渴望中长大，这就是为什么他对他的“加姆加姆”（奶奶）那么依恋。我们稍后会见到她。当安迪还是个孩子时，他的父亲和秘书发生了外遇，正如在《秘书节》中提到的那样。他与埃伦分居，并与秘书和她的孩子组成了另一个家庭。尽管沃尔特和秘书从未正式结婚，
So that was a joke That kind of went against that good bi Toby moment, but it was so funny Sometimes when something was really funny to them they would just go against the show Bible They were like comedy first show Bible later But I want to share a very interesting fan theory sent in by Eva S from from Aurora, Illinois. I absolutely adored it. Here we go. Eva says, we learned so many odd and apparently conflicting things about Andy Bernard's family over the years that I have come up with an explanation that I think ties it all together. Here we go. Andy was born to Walter and Ellen Bernard as we learn in this episode. They favored his younger brother and were emotionally distant from Andy.
但这就是安迪说“要不是因为秘书，我都不会有继母”时所指的人。安迪对她和她的孩子产生了感情。甚至多年以后，他仍会把他们称为他的兄弟姐妹。这就是为什么他在《圣帕特里克节》里说他穿着姐姐的旧曲棍球裙。也是为什么当我们在《PDA》中出海航行时，他会谈到和他的“兄弟们（复数）”一起玩拼图。
He grew up yearning for warm love and acceptance from a family, and this is why he's so attached to his gam-gam. Who we will meet later. When Andy was still a kid, his father had an affair with his secretary, as noted in Secretary's day. Separating from Ellen and setting up a separate household with the secretary and her kids. Even though Walter and the secretary were never officially married,
伊娃接着写道。老沃尔特和埃伦最终去了康涅狄格州纽波特的布雷卡斯酒店，在那里他们决定不离婚。记得那是出自《减肥》那一集。所以，老沃尔特和秘书分手了，结束了安迪的继家庭生活，但他们依然留在他心中。这就是为什么他依然把他们
this is who Andy means when he says, quote, if it wasn't for secretaries, I wouldn't have a stepmom. Andy got attached to her and her kids. Even years later, he will refer to them as his brothers and sister. And this is why he says he's wearing his sisters old field hockey skirt in St. Patrick's Day. And why he talks about doing puzzles with his brothers plural when we're out sailing in PDA.
视为他真正的兄弟姐妹。但是为什么我们在托比的欢送派对上看到了安德鲁和埃伦·伯纳德呢？因为需要让自己看起来体面的安迪，实际上雇了两位社区剧院的演员来假扮他的父母，表现得为他骄傲，以便给同事和安吉拉留下深刻印象，然后他把他的假父亲取名为安德鲁，
Eva goes on. Walter Senior and Ellen end up going to the breakers in Newport, Connecticut, where they decide not to get divorced. Remember that was from weight loss. So Walter, senior broke up with the secretary, putting an end to Andy's step family, but they stayed in his heart. That's why he still thinks of them
这样他终于可以继承父亲的名字了。哦。所以这就是她用来调和所有这些不一致之处的所有理论。伊娃，我觉得你真是全垒打。这让一切都说得通了。伊娃，你可真是帮了我们编剧的大忙了。把所有这些松散的线索串联在一起。我觉得这太棒了。好吧，我们将会发现，安迪的父母没有太多时间待在花园派对上，
as his real brothers and sister. But why did we see Andrew and Ellen Bernard at Toby's going away party? Because Andy, who needs to make himself look good, actually hired two community theater performers to pose at his parents and act proud of him to impress his co-workers and Angela, and then he named his pretend father Andrew
因为他们有剧院的票，要和随后现身的安迪的弟弟去看《点球成金》。他的“兄弟纳德”出席了。嗯哼。这是我们没有听到他被宣布到场时的震惊。没有。我想我们该休息一下了，因为派对上真的要开始发生大事了。是的。
so that he could be his father's name's sake at last. Oh. So those are all of her theories that bring together all of these inconsistencies. Eva, I think you knocked it out of the park. That all made it make sense for me. Eva, you're doing our writers a great service. I'm talking together. All of those loosens. I thought it was fantastic. Well, we're going to find out that Andy's parents don't have much time to be at the garden party
既然小沃尔特已经到了，事情就要变得有趣了。我们马上回来。我们回来了，这一集里我最喜欢的时刻之一发生了。一只乌鸦飞过来，偷走了埃琳头上的帽子。是的，我觉得艾莉的反应太完美了。我太喜欢这个了。你们知道我和我的鸟儿们的交情的，女士。我想，如果有一只鸟从我头上拿走帽子，
because they have theater tickets to see moneyball with Andy's brother who shows up. His bro-nard is in attendance. Mm-hmm. That was the shock we didn't hear him announced. No. I think we should take a break because things are really going to start happening at this party. Yes.
我会觉得：这简直是史上最酷的时刻。发生什么事了？我们收到了来自艾奥瓦州得梅因的梅根·T.关于这一刻的粉丝提问，她问：我必须知道关于鸟拿走埃琳帽子的所有细节。梅根就像你一样，安吉拉。梅根想知道花费了多少钱，训练这只鸟花了多长时间，拍了多少条，以及艾莉·坎珀对此作何感想，因为这会把我吓死。
Now that Walter Jr. has arrived, things are going to get interesting. We'll be right back. We are back, and one of my favorite moments in this whole episode happens. A crow is going to fly and steal Aaron's hat off of her head. Yeah, I thought Ellie's reaction was so perfect. I loved all of this. You know me and my bird's lady. I was like, if a bird took my hat off my head,
哦，也许她不像你。听起来梅根会被吓到。我知道，但梅根也会觉得挺酷的吧？就像，这不是很酷吗。好吧，梅根，我联系了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，想弄清楚我们是怎么拍这一幕的。很抱歉要让你们失望了，这个帽子恶作剧完全是假的。他说特效团队用了一根钓鱼竿和一些类似隐形铁丝的东西，把帽子从艾莉头上拽了下来。她只是对那个动作做出反应。然后他们在后期特效中加上了乌鸦。根本没有训练有素的乌鸦。这就是艾莉演得有多好。确实如此。现在我们要看到一个百分之百
I would be like, this is the coolest moment. What's happening? We got a fan question about this moment from Megan T. and Des Moines, Iowa, who asked, I have to know all the details about the bird taking Aaron's hat. Megan is like you, Angela. Megan would like to know how much did it cost, how long did it take to train the bird, and how many takes did it take, and how did Ellie camper feel about it because it would freak me out.
抄袭自电影《伴娘》的桥段，小沃尔特向吉姆自我介绍，然后以为梅雷迪思是他的妻子帕姆。这个笑话还将再次出现。这是电影《伴娘》中我最喜欢的桥段之一。克里斯汀·韦格角色的身上反复发生这种事。好吧，现在德怀特要和女服务员一起表演一支舞蹈。在这之后本应还有另一个场景：德怀特制作了一个巨大的冰雕。这在被删减片段里。它也在拍摄初稿里。德怀特拿着一把链锯和一个巨大的冰块。他真的很卖力地在雕刻。最后他雕出来的东西看起来只是一团浆糊。我记得这个。他把它推出来，而且对此非常自豪。他说，我向你们呈献：阿拉莫。
Oh, maybe she's not like you. It sounds like Megan would be freaked out. I know, but Megan did also be kind of cool, right? Like, it'd be kind of cool. Well, Megan, I reached out to Steve Burgess to find out how we did this. And I'm sorry to disappoint you, but this hat gag was totally fake. He said that the special effects team used a fishing pole and some like, you know, invisible wire to yank the hat off of Ellie's head. She's just reacting to that. And they added the crow later as special effects. There was no trained crow at all. That's how well Ellie sold it. For sure. Now we're going to have a bit that is 100%
但它看起来只是一团浆糊。然后本应有一个吉姆的独白，吉姆会说：第七章，主人应该总是呈现出一些引人注目的壮观事物来吸引客人的目光。所以我们现在到第七章了。好吧，莫斯还在停车场管理所有的车。他把车停得太近了，以至于他不得不从天窗爬出来。
stolen from the movie Bridesmaids, where Walter Jr. introduces himself to Jim and then thinks that Meredith is his wife Pam. And this joke is going to get repeated. This is one of my favorite bits from the movie Bridesmaids. This happens to Chris and Wiggs' character over and over again. Well Dwight is now going to perform a dance routine with the waitress. And then after this there would have been another scene of Dwight making a giant ice sculpture. It's in deleted scenes. It's also in the shooting draft. Dwight has a chainsaw and a huge block of ice. And he's really just carving away. And what he ends up with is just something that looks like a blob. I remember this. He rolls it out and he's really proud of it. And he says, I give you the Alamo.
我们收到了来自威斯康星州米卡拉·G.的粉丝提问，她说：在9分51秒时，当莫斯把所有的车都停在田野里时，所有车辆的挡风玻璃上都有这些亮绿色的纸条。所有车辆的挡风玻璃上都有这些亮绿色纸条。那是什么？有没有被删减的场景来解释那是什么？米卡拉，我也注意到了这个，安吉拉。是的。如果你实际上回到2分35秒，也就是会议室里剧集刚开始的时候，每个人都分发到了一张纸。看起来上面写着“舒鲁特农场停车证”，就像一张绿色的传单。是的。德怀特有一句被剪掉的台词，他说：把它撕成三份。一份是地图，一份是你的邀请函，最后一份是你的停车证。把它放在你的仪表盘上。所以，好眼力，米卡拉。眼力真好。德怀特现在要宣布罗伯特·加利福尼亚的到来。
But it just looks like a blob. And then there would have been a gym talking head where Jim would have said, chapter seven, the host should always present something spectacular to draw the eye of the guests. So we're at chapter seven now. Well, most is still managing all the cars in the parking lot. He's parked them so close together that he exits through the sunroofs.
他挥舞手臂的时间实在是太长了。在拍摄初稿里，珍娜，就在罗伯特以真正的罗伯特·加利福尼亚式戏剧化风格抵达后，他走过去站在一台拖拉机旁。他凝视着农场四周，然后转身面对镜头说了这样一段话。我有这段剪辑。我们听听看。这一切都取决于雨水打湿、倚靠着白色母鸡的、泛着光泽的红色独轮车。威廉·卡洛斯·威廉斯。太美了。然后他戏剧性地走开了。我查了一下威廉·卡洛斯·威廉斯，根据诗歌基金会的资料，
And we got a famed catch from Mikala G. in Wisconsin, who said, at nine minutes and 51 seconds, when Moze is parking all of the cars in the field, there are these bright green colored pieces of paper on all the vehicle's windshields. There are these bright green colored pieces of paper on all the vehicles windshields. What are they? Is there a deleted scene that explains what they are? Michaela, I notice these as well, Angela. Yeah. If you actually go to two minutes and 35 seconds, the very beginning of the episode when they're in the conference room, everyone has been handed out. It looks like it says parking for shrewd farms, like a green flyer. Yes, Dwight has a line that was cut where he says, rip it in thirds. One is the map, one is your invitation, and the last is your parking pass. Just put it on your dashboard. So good catch, Michaela. Very good catch. Dwight is now going to announce the arrival of Robert California.
他是一位医学博士、诗人、小说家、散文家和剧作家。威廉斯是意象派运动的领军诗人，经常以美国题材和主题进行写作。尽管他的职业生涯最初被其他诗人所掩盖，但他成为了20世纪50和60年代垮掉的一代灵感来源。他被称为实验者和创新者，是美国诗歌界具有革命性的人物。这太随机了。我很好奇
He like rolls his arm for so long. In the shooting draft Jenna, right after Robert arrives in true Robert California dramatic fashion, he goes and he stands by a tractor. He gazes out around the farm and then he turns to camera and he says this. I have the clip. Let's hear it. So much depends upon a red wheelbarrow glazed with rainwater beside the white chickens. William Carlos Williams. Beautiful. And then he dramatically walks away. I looked up William Carlos Williams, according to the Poetry Foundation.
我们的哪个编剧是个诗歌迷并了解他。我知道，因为要让罗伯特·加利福尼亚引用这个，这是一个相当具体的诗人和诗句。这也非常契合罗伯特·加利福尼亚这个角色。我也这么觉得，而且超级戏剧化，我其实希望它能保留在正片里，因为它太随机、太诡异了。好吧，罗伯特带来的不是橘子酱。不，他带的是罗勒，他本来打算带的就是这个。我们现在看到凯文和莱恩在玩跷跷板。莱恩情况不太妙。没有，他是那个被悬在半空中下不来的人。然后本应有一场
He was a medical doctor, poet, novelist, essayist, and playwright. Williams was a leading poet of the imaginist movement and often wrote of American subjects and themes. Though his career was initially overshadowed by other poets, he became an inspiration to the beat generation of the 1950s and 60s. He was known as an experimenter and innovator, a revolutionary figure in American poetry. It's very random. I wonder which
场景，珍娜，发生在安吉拉和帕姆之间，在干杯之前。里面全是讽刺。满满的讽刺。这就是我们在室内拍摄的那场戏，部分原因是为了让你凉快点，因为外面太热了，他们担心你在室外。但是，是的，我想我们必须听听这场戏。拍摄初稿里的设定是这样的。内景，舒鲁特农场，主屋。帕姆拿着婴儿监视器走下楼梯。安吉拉坐在起居室里。我给这场戏起名为，珍娜。就是这样。我们听听看。小西西睡着了吗？是的，她刚睡下。真是个宝贵的小天使。
of our writers is a poetry fan and knew about him. I know, because that's a pretty specific poet and line to have Robert California quote. I'm very perfect for the character of Robert California as well. I thought so too, and it's super dramatic, and I kind of wish it had stayed in because it's so random and bizarre. Well, Robert has brought not the Marmalade. No, he brought the basil plant, which he was going to bring all along. We're going to see Kevin and Ryan now on the seasaw. It's not going so well for Ryan. No, he's the one stuck up in the air there. And then there would have been
哦，塞西莉亚。还有菲利普。是的，随我祖父的名字。菲利普在你身上真是浪费了。吉姆才不会花时间——
a scene, Jenna here, between Angela and Pam, that comes before the toast. It is packed with sass. So much sass. It's the scene we shot inside, partially so you could cool off, because it was so hot and they were worried about you being outside. But yeah, I think we have to hear this scene. It was set up in the shooting draft like this. Interior Shrute Farms, main house. Pam comes down the stairs holding a baby monitor. Angela is sitting in the living room. I'm titling the scene, Jenna. And that is that. Let's hear it. Little CC asleep. Yeah, she just went down. Such a precious little angel.
哦，还有菲利普。是的，随我祖父的名字。菲利普在你身上真是浪费了。吉姆才不会花时间叫他菲利普呢。他连理发的时间都没有。而且菲尔！呃！这简直是对一个人的折磨！
Oh, Cecilia. And Philip. Yes, after my grandfather. Philip is wasted on you. Jim is never going to take the timehmm. And Philip. Yes, after my grandfather. Philip is wasted on you. Jim is never going to take the time to call him Philip. He doesn't even take the time to get a haircut. And Phil! Ugh! It's just something you do to a whole!
好吧，我的宝宝先出生，所以就是这样。你知道吗？这很难说。我的医生说我的骨盆太纤细了，所以，嗯，毫无疑问，我得做剖腹产。所以，我可能会早产。你觉得你的医生会在你六个月大的时候——所以，我可能会早产。你觉得你的医生会在你六个月大的时候给你做剖腹产吗？对，如果我要求的话，他会做的。
Well, I'm having my baby first, so that's that. You know what? It could go either way. My doctor said my hips are so dainty that, um, most definitely, I have a C-section. So, I could go early. You think your doctor is going to give you a C-section at so I could go early. You think your doctor's gonna give you a C-section at six months? Yeah, if I request it, you will.
就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。我真的很失望这场戏没有保留下来，因为后来当我们在农舍中央发现西西和她的便携婴儿床孤零零地呆着时，我对帕姆和吉姆的育儿方式产生了疑问。我当时想：搞什么鬼？
And that is that. And that is that. And that is that. I am really disappointed that this scene did not stand because later when we find Cece and her pack and play all alone in the middle of the farmhouse, I had questions about Pam and Jim's parenting. I was like, what the heck?
你们去哪了？她当时在查看她的宝宝。她有婴儿监视器，她正在查看。西西当时在睡觉。她现在醒了而且很安静，但曾经有一会儿她把熟睡的孩子留在那里，如果能交代一下这个信息就好了。好吧，安迪的父母要走了，但在他们离开之前，安迪非常想敬个酒。哦，天哪，祝酒。我知道。他要为他出色的员工举杯。
What happened to you? I was checking on her baby. She has a baby monitor and she is checking in. And Seese was sleeping. She's now awake and quiet, but there was a moment when she left her sleeping, which was information I would have liked to have known. Well, Andy's parents are going to leave, but before they do, Andy really wants to make a toast. Oh my gosh, the toasts. I know. He's going to raise his glass to his amazing staff.
在拍摄初稿中，安迪的祝酒词更长，以下是他对员工的评价。我只想借此机会感谢你们来到我的员工中间。吉姆、德怀特、斯坦利、菲利斯，公司的顶梁柱。致凯文、安吉拉、奥斯卡，大脑，达里尔，灵魂，凯莉，嘴巴，加布，鼻子，梅雷迪思、埃琳，脸面。这是一个很好的删减。我知道。
In the shooting draft, Andy's toast was longer, and here's what he said about his staff. I just wanted to take this chance to thank you for coming to my staff. Jim Dwight Stanley Phyllis, the backbone of the company. To Kevin, Angela, Oscar, the brains, Darryl, the soul, Kelly, the mouth, Gabe, the nose, Meredith, Erin, the face. This was a good cut. I know.
这太迈克尔·斯科特了。这确实非常迈克尔·斯科特。这里面残留了太多迈克尔·斯科特的影子。我想他们删掉是正确的。而且，安迪没有列出帕姆。哦，好吧。那删掉就更对了，因为帕姆没有得到她应有的高光时刻。
This is two Michael Scott. It is very Michael Scott. This is too many remnants of Michael Scott. They were right to cut that, I think. Also, Andy did not list Pam. Oh, well. Then even better that it was cut because Pam did not get her moment.
这就是两个迈克尔·斯科特。这非常迈克尔·斯科特。迈克尔·斯科特的痕迹太多了。我认为他们剪掉这一段是对的。而且，安迪没有把帕姆列出来。哦，好吧。那被剪掉就更好了，因为帕姆没有得到她的高光时刻。
Andy's really hoping by doing these toasts that people then will reciprocate to him. And it really backfires. All anyone wants to toast is Robert, California. Until Angela has a toast to her baby, Philip Lipden. Yes, who's doing four months, but she's gonna announce the baby's name now. And then Pam is gonna toast her baby, Philip Halpert, who is due even sooner. She's going to explain the significance of the name Philip and really drives it home that this has been a promise that she made her grandfather when she was a little girl and it has a lot of significance to her family. Angela is going to have a talking head where she's crying and she's like, Pam copies
安迪真的很希望通过这些祝酒，别人也能对他回敬一番。结果却适得其反。所有人只想向罗伯特·加利福尼亚祝酒。直到安吉拉为她的宝宝菲利普·利普登（Philip Lipden）祝酒。没错，虽然还要四个月才出生，但她现在就要宣布孩子的名字。然后帕姆要为她的宝宝菲利普·哈尔珀特（Philip Halpert）祝酒，这个宝宝预产期更早。她要解释菲利普这个名字的意义，并着重强调这是她小时候对爷爷许下的承诺，对她的家族有着重大的意义。安吉拉有一个采访镜头，她在里面哭着说，帕姆抄袭了
everything I do. It's the Ford Tourist situation all over again. We had a fan question from Jake B. and Tulsa Oklahoma who says, Angela mentions the Ford Tourist situation, what is this? Because in the show, Pam drives a Toyota Yaris and Angela drives a Saturn. Jake, I don't know. Jake, here's my fan theory on this.
我做的一切。这简直就是福特金牛座事件的重演。我们收到了来自俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨市的杰克·B.的粉丝提问，他说，安吉拉提到了福特金牛座事件，这是什么意思？因为在剧里，帕姆开的是丰田雅力士，安吉拉开的是土星。杰克，我不知道。杰克，这是我对这件事的粉丝理论。
Okay. They have worked together for a long, long time. And I feel like one of the first cards that they bought was a Ford Taurus and Angela got one and then Pam got one and copied her and she was ticked off. Well, why do you think Angela got the Taurus first? Maybe Pam got it.
好吧。他们共事了很长时间、很长时间。我觉得他们买的第一批车里有一辆福特金牛座，安吉拉买了一辆，然后帕姆也买了一辆并抄袭了她，这把她气坏了。那么，你为什么觉得安吉拉先买的金牛座呢？也许是帕姆先买的呢？
Well, because she says Pam copies everything I do. So it seemed like two. Angela thinks Pam is copying the baby name Philip, but Angela is wrong. Pam's had this name forever. She's not copying anything. She said her baby was gonna be named Philip before Angela even said anything.
嗯，因为她说帕姆抄袭了她做的一切。所以感觉像是两回事。安吉拉以为帕姆在宝宝名字菲利普上抄袭了她，但安吉拉猜错了。帕姆用这个名字很久很久了。她没有抄袭任何东西。早在安吉拉开口之前，她就说过她的宝宝要叫菲利普了。
Well, here's the thing. You don't know who's copying who, because in Angela's mind, she always thought if she had a baby, she'd name it Philip after her very first cat, Philip. We've never heard of Philip the cat. Never. We've been married.
好吧，事情是这样的。你不知道是谁在抄袭谁，因为在安吉拉的心里，她一直觉得如果她有了孩子，她会用她第一只猫的名字——菲利普，来给孩子命名。我们从来没听说过叫菲利普的猫。从来没有。我们结婚以后。
We've never seen her favorite cat. Have we ever heard of Philip the grandfather? Have we ever heard of Philip the grandfather? Ever. No. Wow. Wow, this rivalry has turned real. Well, guess what?
我们从来没见过她最喜欢的猫。我们听说过爷爷叫菲利普吗？我们听说过爷爷叫菲利普吗？从来没有。哇。哇，这场竞争已经白热化了。好吧，你猜怎么着？
After these toes, Kelly is going to have a toast where she throws shade at both Angela and Pam. It's in deleted scenes. She stands up and says, I'd like to toast the non-pregnant ladies and how we don't just make our own personal issues, everyone's issues, because the rest of us don't really care. Okay, Kelly's had it. She has had it with big pricks, little pricks. Aaron is finally about to propose a toast to Andy but gets interrupted by Dwight who announces they need to do a tablo of the last supper.
在这些祝酒之后，凯利要发表一段祝酒词，对安吉拉和帕姆冷嘲热讽了一番。这在删减片段里。她站起来说，我想向未怀孕的女士们祝酒，感谢我们没有把自己个人的问题变成所有人的问题，因为我们其余的人其实并不在乎。好吧，凯利受够了。她受够了大混蛋和小混蛋了。艾琳终于准备向安迪提议祝酒，却被德怀特打断了，德怀特宣布他们需要摆一个“最后的晚餐”的造型。
We're at chapter 9. Chapter 9 now. I want to point something out in Jim's talking head when he's reading, chapter 9 now. I wanna point something out in Jim's talking head when he's reading from chapter 9 at 12 minutes and 37 seconds, you can see very clearly that all the pages in the book are blank. Blank. Oh, there's nothing written, there's no typing, nothing.
我们到了第9章。现在是第9章。我想指出吉姆在12分37秒朗读第9章时的采访镜头里的一个细节，你可以非常清楚地看到书里的所有页面都是空白的。空白的。哦，上面什么都没写，没有打印，什么都没有。
I have to bring up a Stanley runner that was going on throughout the whole episode that got cut. It's indelated scenes if you have the DVDs. I thought Leslie did such a great job and so I want to share about it. Oh, please. So early in the episode, Stanley asks Andy if he can bring Cynthia as his date and fill us under her breath is like, don't do it Stanley. That idea. She's like, don't do it. And then Stanley has a talking head where he shares that he has been wanting to break up
我得提一下贯穿整集的一个被剪掉的斯坦利的小插曲。如果你有DVD的话，它在删减片段里。我觉得莱斯利表现得太棒了，所以我想分享一下。哦，请吧。在这集刚开始的时候，斯坦利问安迪他能不能带辛西娅当他的女伴，菲利斯在旁边小声说，别这么做，斯坦利。那个主意。她说，别这么做。然后斯坦利有一个采访镜头，他在里面分享说他一直想和
with his current girlfriend, Cynthia, but he wants to do it at a public place. He explains that he likes to break up at a restaurant but doesn't like to spend money that doesn't lead to sex. So this garden party is perfect. Oh my gosh. I know. And then as Gabe is chatting up Cynthia throughout the party
他现任女友辛西娅分手，但他想在一个公共场所这么做。他解释说，他喜欢在餐馆分手，但不喜欢花那些不能带来性爱的钱。所以这个花园派对太完美了。哦，天哪。我懂。然后当盖布在派对自始至终都在跟辛西娅套近乎时
and Stanley goes, don't get too close. I want a clean break. And then he finally does break up with her. And she goes off on him in front of everyone and says that she will be letting his wife know where she can pick him up. Wow. Yeah. And Phyllis is like, I told you Stanley.
斯坦利说，别走太近。我想来个痛快的断交。然后他终于和她分手了。她在所有人面前对他大发雷霆，并说她会让他妻子知道去哪里接他。哇。是的。菲利斯则说，我早就告诉你了，斯坦利。
It was a whole runner. It was huge. Wow. Well, listen, if you thought the toasts were over, they're not. Kevin is now going to toast Robert California. Gabe is going to try to toast Robert California. And then Robert would like to say a few words. He would like to propose a toast to everyone in the office. Because really the bosses are relevant. That's right. They don't really do anything. Like the difference between a crying baby and a manager. Yeah. The crying baby grows up. This is not helping Andy with his hopes
这是一个完整的小插曲。规模很大。哇。好吧，听着，如果你以为祝酒已经结束了，那就大错特错了。凯文现在要向罗伯特·加利福尼亚祝酒。盖布要试着向罗伯特·加利福尼亚祝酒。然后罗伯特想说几句话。他想向办公室里的所有人祝酒。因为实际上老板们是无关紧要的。没错。他们其实什么都不做。就像哭泣的婴儿和经理的区别一样。对。哭泣的婴儿会长大。这对于安迪希望
of having someone toast him and say nice things. Well, Andy is gonna take control of things and he is gonna suggest that he and his father sing a duet. He's gonna get out his guitar and start playing and his dad has a lot of comments. It's the wrong key. It just constantly stops him.
有人向他祝酒并说好话的愿望一点帮助也没有。好吧，安迪要掌控全局了，他建议他和他的父亲合唱一首。他要拿出吉他开始弹奏，而他爸爸有很多意见。调子不对。他一直在不断地打断他。
Yes. And then when they do finally start singing, my heart broke for Andy because Andy starts to do his and a thing because they're dirt of voice. Yeah. He does his Andy voice that is not meshing at all with his dad's voice and his dad's going to stop it. His dad is going to stop it and call up Walter Jr. Who, as we all know, is played by a man who has one of the most beautiful voices
是的。然后当他们终于开始唱歌时，我的心都为安迪碎了，因为安迪开始发出他那种安迪式的声音，因为他们的嗓音很不搭。是的。他唱出了那种完全无法与他爸爸的声音融合的安迪嗓音，他爸爸要制止他。他爸爸要制止他，并叫出了小沃尔特。众所周知，小沃尔特由一位拥有这个星球上最美妙嗓音的男士扮演
to grace this planet, Josh Groban. Oh my gosh, we actually got a fan comment from Marissa Kay. In Illinois who said, I absolutely loved that they picked Josh Groban to be Andy's brother, and I thought it was tragically hilarious to have Walter Jr. be a noticeably better singer than Andy because Andy loves to sing so much. There are so many layers to this family and their dynamic. Oh my gosh.
那就是乔诗·葛洛班。哦，天哪，我们确实收到了来自伊利诺伊州的玛丽莎·K.的粉丝评论，她说，我绝对喜欢他们选择乔诗·葛洛班来扮演安迪的弟弟，而且我觉得让小沃尔特明显比安迪唱得好听，这种设定具有一种悲剧性的滑稽感，因为安迪那么喜欢唱歌。这个家庭以及他们的家庭动态有太多的层次感了。哦，天哪。
I know people talk about Scott's thoughts as being the cringiest episode. I found this episode, and particularly this scene and the scenes to follow with Andy trying to oppress his dad and never getting anywhere to be so incredibly uncomfortable to watch. And then there is no resolution. There's never a moment where Andy gets what he needed. I was so uncomfortable this whole time.
我知道人们说《斯科特的想法》是最让人尴尬的一集。我发现这一集，尤其是这一场戏以及随后的安迪试图向他父亲倾诉却毫无结果的戏，看起来让人感到难以置信的不舒服。而且最后也没有一个结局。从来没有一个安迪得到了他所需要的东西的时刻。我这一整集都觉得好不舒服。
Well, he doesn't get what he needs from his parents, but kind of like Michael Scott, his co-workers are becoming his family. Did you see that parallel? A little bit? A little bit. But I'm not imagining that Andy is going home after this garden party, not being like kind of still wounded.
嗯，他没有从父母那里得到他需要的东西，但有点像迈克尔·斯科特，他的同事们正在成为他的家人。你看到那个平行关系了吗？有一点？有一点。但我并没有想象安迪在参加了这个花园派对后回家，心里不会觉得依然有点受伤。
Well, yeah. I don't know. Well, to break up this tragedy with a little comedy, Mo's is going to what? He's going to jump over the row of cars in a Vespa? What? He's going to have his evil, con evil moment. Yeah. It doesn't make it. So then he just runs across the top of it.
嗯，是的。我不知道。好吧，为了用一点喜剧来打破这种悲剧，莫斯要干嘛？他要骑着Vespa飞越一排汽车？什么？他要上演他的“疯狂伊凡”时刻。是的。他没飞过去。所以他最后直接从车顶上跑过去了。
Fan question from Amanda and Ontario, what was the process behind the stunt where Moe's runs across the roofs of the car? Well, Steve Burgess said there was a lot of prep involved and that we originally really did want to have Moe's ride the scooter across the cars. But Universal said no. They said it would cause too much damage to the cars. It would be too expensive. They weren't concerned, I guess, about the safety. They were concerned
来自安大略省阿曼达的粉丝提问，莫斯跑过车顶的特技背后的制作过程是怎样的？嗯，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说这其中涉及大量的准备工作，我们最初确实希望让莫斯骑着踏板车穿过汽车。但环球影城说不。他们说这会对汽车造成太大的损坏。这会太昂贵。我想他们关心的不是安全问题。他们关心的是
about the cost of that. Yeah, that's what it sounds like. So as an alternative, they decided to have not make sure, but a stunt double run across the cars. But Steve Burgess said that actually caused quite a bit of damage and was very costly anyway. Just a person running on the top of the cars. Yes, it dented in the tops of the cars. I want to say that I thought the stunt guy playing Mose did an excellent job of running like Mose. It was a very good Mose run. Yeah, because Mike sure has a weird run as Mose. I know. This guy really sold it. Robert, California and Dwight have a very funny exchange where, you know, Dwight's
成本问题。是的，听起来是这样的。所以作为替代方案，他们决定不让莫斯去，而是让一个特技替身演员跑过汽车。但史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，这实际上还是造成了相当大的损坏，而且无论如何成本都很高。仅仅是一个人在车顶上跑。是的，把车顶都踩凹了。我想说，我觉得扮演莫斯的那个特技演员把莫斯那种跑法演得太棒了。那是一种非常地道的莫斯的跑法。是的，因为迈克·舒尔跑起步来就很奇怪。我知道。这家伙真的演活了。罗伯特·加利福尼亚和德怀特有一段非常有趣的对话，你知道，德怀特
talking about the beat farm and Robert's like, forget the beats. You should rent this place out. I would pay a considerable amount of money to have my birthday party here. And then Dwight goes into great detail about all the different birthday packages they offer, and they all include a lot of goats, a lot of goats. Some more than others, some are all goats, some are just a few goats.
谈论着甜菜农场，而罗伯特却说，忘掉甜菜吧。你应该把这个地方租出去。我愿意花一大笔钱在这里举办我的生日派对。然后德怀特就开始详细介绍他们提供的各种生日套餐，而且所有套餐都包含大量的山羊，大量的山羊。有些套餐山羊更多，有些全都是山羊，有些只有几只山羊。
Robert California is a line that's so funny. He's like, why are you talking to me about these ghosts? Yeah, he said you're not interested. I'm literally not interested. I'm not interested. I'm explaining the ghosts. Yeah, I just loved it. I loved it too.
罗伯特·加利福尼亚有句台词太搞笑了。他说，你为什么跟我谈论这些山羊？是的，他说你又不感兴趣。我确实不感兴趣。我不感兴趣。我在解释山羊的事。Yeah, I just loved it. 我也太喜欢了。
He's gonna offer to get Robert some exotic meats. And then when Robert walks away, he says they're all goat. Yeah. I don't know if this was from the mind of Justin Spitzer, or if this was a bit that was written by a breakout room with one of the writers, but it was fantastic. I loved it so much. I went to deleted scenes hoping that it was extended,
他要主动提出给罗伯特弄点异国肉类。然后当罗伯特走开时，他说这些全都是山羊肉。是的。我不知道这是贾斯蒂斯·斯皮策的想法，还是某个编剧房间里由其中一位编剧写的一个段子，但它太棒了。我太喜欢了。我去看删减片段，希望它能长一点，
that there was more Robert, California, and Dwight discussing goats, but there wasn't. Ah. Well, if you wanted to get your heart broken, the next scene is going to do it. Oh gosh. Yeah. Andy is talking to Cece and his dad comes in and just really just belittles him just horribly.
希望有更多罗伯特·加利福尼亚和德怀特讨论山羊的内容，但并没有。啊。好吧，如果你想让心碎，下一幕就要做到了。哦，天哪。是的。安迪正在和西西说话，他爸爸走了进来，对他进行了一番极其刻薄的贬低。
And the whole time it's over the baby monitor, we find out that Oscar and Dural and Pam and Jim and Aaron have overheard the whole conversation. He's told him he's not proud of him that he's the manager of a rinky dink paper company in scranton, just as horrible. And then his parents leave. That's it. There is no hug. There's no we're proud of you anyway. There's nothing positive. I did love the parents talking head because I absolutely loved it when Dee Wallace said the sandwiches were dry. I really, I really loved it.
整个过程都是通过婴儿监视器传出来的，我们发现奥斯卡、达里尔、帕姆、吉姆和艾琳听到了整个对话。他告诉安迪他为他感到骄傲，说他是斯克兰顿一家破烂小纸业公司的经理，这话真是太恶毒了。然后他父母就走了。就这样。没有拥抱。没有一句“不管怎样我们都为你骄傲”。什么积极的话都没有。我确实很喜欢父母的那个采访镜头，因为当迪·华莱士说三明治很干的时候，我真的太喜欢了。
It was a very like parents moment, like especially if you've planned your wedding, there's always some aunt and uncle or someone that has a comment that's like, all I liked everything, but you know, the bread was hard or something. It's true. Then we have what I think is a little bit
这非常符合父母的性格，尤其是如果你筹办过婚礼，总会有某个七大姑八大姨或是某个人会发表这样的评论，比如，我什么都喜欢，但你知道，面包太硬了之类的话。确实如此。然后我们迎来了我认为可以说是安迪的
of a redemption moment for Andy. Everyone is hanging out. It's very casual now. Darrell is working the grill, Oscar tosses the Nard Dog, a cold one, and Andy sits down on a picnic blanket, and it fills warm and cozy and so friendly, and boy did Andy need this at the end of this day. It's true.
某种救赎时刻的片段。大家都在闲逛。现在气氛非常随意。达里尔在烤肉，奥斯卡给“纳德狗”扔了一罐冰镇饮料，安迪在一块野餐毯上坐了下来，感觉温暖、舒适而又友善，天哪，安迪在经历这一天的最后确实需要这个。确实如此。
We're gonna have a final moment from Dwight as well, a final performance. It is a torch dance, a fire dance with the staff. This was of course from James Trickington's book about closing ceremonies. Mm-hmm. We had a fan question from Rebecca G. in Texas who said how long did it take for
我们还将迎来德怀特最后的时刻，最后的表演。这是一场火炬舞，是一场与员工一起进行的火舞。这当然出自詹姆斯·特灵顿关于闭幕式的书。嗯哼。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州丽贝卡·G.的粉丝提问，她说雷恩·威尔逊花了多长时间
Rain Wilson to learn the dance at the end of the episode and Ryan S. from Massachusetts would like to know how many safety meetings were there about the use of fire in the closing ceremonies. Steve Burgess said that those dancers were an actual fire dance group. Amazing. And that Mary Ann Kellogg was our choreographer. He said, Rain Wilson learned that choreography and worked with the fire dancers for a couple of hours earlier that morning in order to do that scene. And as far as safety, Steber just said we had a lot of safety meetings all the time.
才学会这集结尾的舞蹈，马萨诸塞州的瑞安·S.想知道在闭幕式上使用火焰时究竟开了多少次安全会议。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，那些舞者是一个真正的火舞团。太惊人了。玛丽安·凯洛格是我们的编舞。他说，雷恩·威尔逊那天早上早些时候花了好几个小时学习了那段编舞并与火舞演员一起排练，以便完成那个场景。至于安全问题，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们一直在开很多安全会议。
We had a big one first thing in the morning where we talked all about the day. I believe he reiterated the rattlesnakes, he reiterated the bees, he told us to hydrate and he mentioned that later in the day we would have fire. I remember our morning safety meeting and I remember them introducing us to our snake wrangler. Yes, I remember it because I'll never forget, you know, if you get bit by a rattlesnake, you are not supposed to run because that makes the venom move more quickly through your system. You're not supposed to have a person who has been bit by a rattlesnake, move themselves out of the area. you are supposed to get someone to carry
一大早我们就开了一个大会，把一整天的事情都讨论了一遍。我想他再次强调了响尾蛇的事，再次强调了蜜蜂的事，他告诉我们要补充水分，还提到当天晚些时候我们会有火。我记得我们早上的安全会议，我记得他们把我们介绍给了我们的驯蛇师。是的，我记得，因为我永远不会忘记，你知道的，如果你被响尾蛇咬了，你绝对不能跑，因为那会让毒液在你的系统里扩散得更快。你绝不能让一个被响尾蛇咬了的人自己走出那个区域。你应该找个人把
them out. And that was the whole thing, that it was like you're supposed to scream for help, so that you can be carried out of the area. I just remember the guy had these really tall boots on. And you and I were walking around in little high heels or flats and I was like, should we all have the tall boots? Yes. Where are the boots? I want some boots. Yes. Steve said we also fireproofed all of the wardrobe for the fire dancers. And we had another safety meeting right before the fire dance started. And that's how it all went down. Before our rewatch is done of the office. I really want Kelly can't lead to come on. And I want her to do a full safety meeting on the pod. Absolutely. It has to happen. This episode ends with a tag. It is Jim
他们背出来。这就是全部的重点，意思是你应该大声呼救，这样你才能被抬出那个区域。我只记得那家伙穿着一双很高的靴子。你和我当时穿着小高跟鞋或平底鞋四处走动，我就想，我们是不是都该穿那种高筒靴？对。靴子在哪儿？我也想要几双靴子。是的。史蒂夫说我们还对火舞演员的所有戏服进行了防火处理。在火舞开始前，我们又开了一次安全会议。事情就是这样进行的。在我们重温办公室之旅结束之前。我真的很想让凯利·坎特利来上播客。我想让她在播客里开一次完整的安全会议。绝对的。这必须得发生。这一集的结尾是一个彩蛋。是吉姆
pranking Dwight. This prank made more sense to me. Okay. He's just going to enter the party over and over so that Dwight is constantly having to say Jim Malpert. And he's like asking him questions like, who's the best salesman in the branch? And then he exits that he comes back in, Jim Halpert. And he just does this over and over. I loved this whole bit of rain announcing everyone and shouting as Dwight. I thought it was a fun way to end the episode.
捉弄德怀特。这个恶作剧对我有更多的吸引力。好吧。他只是一次又一次地进入派对，以至于德怀特不得不 constamment 地说“吉姆·哈尔珀特”。他会问他一些问题，比如，分公司里最好的销售员是谁？然后他离开，又走回来，说“吉姆·哈尔珀特”。他一遍又一遍地这样做。我太喜欢雷恩用德怀特的嗓音播报所有人并大喊大叫的整个桥段了。我觉得这是结束这一集的一种有趣方式。
I want to say that I thought that this garden party with all of these weird elements was actually quite charming and interesting, and like Robert California, I would be interested in having that party. Forget the beats. Focus on parties. Minus the goats. Exactly.
我想说，我觉得这个有着所有这些奇奇怪怪元素的远足派对实际上相当迷人且有趣，就像罗伯特·加利福尼亚一样，我也很有兴趣办那样一个派对。忘掉甜菜吧。专注于派对。抛开山羊不谈。没错。
Yeah. Well, there you have it, everybody. That was Garden Party. Thanks so much for listening. Thank you so much to Josh Groban for stopping by. What an absolute delight. And thank you to Steve Burgess for all his great insider info.
好吧，大家，这就是全部内容了。这就是《花园派对》。非常感谢大家的收听。非常感谢乔诗·葛洛班的光临。真是一件绝对令人高兴的事。也非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯提供的所有精彩内部消息。
Yes, and next week we will be back with Sput. Oh, that's a Halloween episode. Yeah, Halloween in June. Bye, you guys. Bye. Bye you guys! Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies! Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is Executive Produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
是的，下周我们将回归《Sput》。哦，那是万圣节特辑。是的，六月的万圣节。再见，各位。再见。再见，各位！再见！感谢收听“办公室淑女”！“办公室淑女”由Ear Wolf制作，珍妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西共同打造。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our sound engineer is Sam Keifer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbleco. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For add free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitcher Premium dot com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code office. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾斯莉·巴布科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的“办公室淑女”，请访问Stitcher Premium dot com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码office。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。